What was he even you calling? Was it just the mattress in the
standing desk
>> I just want to point out that Ice Poseidon is doing
a 3:00 a.m. depression stream playing while venting about his
relationship. He's like one bowl of curry away from just being
Darius. Okay.
>> Well, treat everyone with respect and peace. But he's
not a victim.
He's not a victim. He's not. He's not. >> I mean, >> I
don't trust anyone.
I don't trust
>> Yes. Hold on. Wait. That was not said before. Hold on.
That Tim Cuz I thought what Tim was told. Okay. Was >> he
like Ice did not hear the version where like she blew him in
in a U-Haul and him on like a mattressless floor >> Yeah.
I We did not hear the U-Haul story on the Yeah, I was about to
say Jesus.
Are we ready? Buckle in. This is our This is our Hunger Games
or our scavenger hunt content for the day and then we're going
to get into the Roblox stuff after this. So, I hope you guys
are ready to go. All right, man. I'm like I'll be honest. You
guys got to hop into the Twitch. Okay, you got to hop You know
what? Never mind. The Twitch is gone. The Twitch is gone. We're
going to take the Twitch down. There's just no reason. I got
like 10 times the audience on uh I get like a hundred times the
audience on kick right now. Sorry. And it does uh it just costs
money. though. Unlucky. Twitchers. Unlucky. You guys don't show
out. I'll shut off multi streaming and we'll just go kick only.
All right. You kick. Where's kick only today.
Who is Hannah in relation to Ice? Hannah Rididgeway is Sam Peppers.
So Sam Pepper being very close to Ice Poseidon. Sam Pepper's
ex-wife, but they're still not divorced. Apparently, there's
a fight there over Sam being able to get divorced. I think I
think Hannah wants some cash from him is what I've heard. And
so she wants to get divorced and he won't get divorced and he
just sits in Thailand by himself. Well, with a girlfriend. I
just click back in. And you're watching a video about this Mr.
by Mr. Bean. It's not Mr. Bean. That is a photoshop of Ice Boseidon.
Philippines. Oh, I thought it was Thailand. Philippines. Sure.
Philippines. Philippines. Philippines.
You know, I I tend to morph these things. I tend to merge them
together in my head. I need an expert like legal mindset to explain
them to me. Okay. I I don't know the finer points of of Passport
Brodom. Okay. I don't I don't know the finer points. So, here
we go. Here we go. Oh, was there a new log again?
Is there more? No, I've got I think I've got all the logs here.
We got all the logs. We've got a imaginary fanboy in the Discord
right now. I asked him if he's a food shops member. He said a
food shops community member and he said he's a drama enjoyer
and a Dan orbiter. Funny how those two things put together, you
know, being a fan of Dan and being a drama follower, you end
up in a Discord community. I'm just saying that's very strange
to me. It's very
bizarre. Okay. I would I personally feel like Dan wouldn't want
those optics out there, but that's if you want to say that. Okay.
All right. All right. Let's go.
>> Handridge going ham for Kimmy and going hard on Ice
Beside. Let's check it out. I'm not understanding how Paul's
the victim. I am not understanding how Paul's the victim.
>> Oh, good. Gary's take. Gary's take, guys. Gary's take
on the drama. >> I mean, like I said last night, if anything,
it's a good thing if it was true, cuz now if he didn't know,
and now he knows, >> then good that he knows. So then,
>> let me just tell you, Paul knew. Paul knew all of it.
Paul knew everything. Paul knew. Hands down. Hands to God. Paul
knew everything. I know him. Oh.
So this person also, she's really good friend of both. So she
knew Ice beside she hung out with them a bunch. Being the wife
of ex-wife of Sam Pepper, she hung around these people a whole
bunch, right? So she's saying Paul knew. She goes on to tell
some stories about exactly how and why Paul knew. >> Poor
Paul. Poor Paul. I saw his stream today. I saw all the subs he
was getting. I saw his psychopathic first 20 minutes of stream
full cam of him looking like he just buried a his backyard. I
saw I saw all of you guys gifting subs. I saw that Paul. Poor
Paul. Paul's the victim. Paul didn't know. Oh, poor Paul. He
knew. [__] Paul knew. Kimmy's friends knew. It >> Could
you Could you like not say that though, Hannah? Cuz I'm just
telling you, we got a song and it's pretty good. And the basis
of the song kind of cuts against that. So,
I should we let the truth get in the way of the the the AI cover?
Really? a long ass time ago. Paul knew. Okay. How was Paul the
victim? They were broken up. Paul so many. Paul cheated on Kimmy.
That's why they broke up in the first place. Oh, and she a guy
she guy she was living with. Oh my god. What a psycho [__]
Oh my god. What a psycho [__] If it if it was reversed,
if this was reversed, everyone >> she's like just she's
just a touch performative, right? She's a little little over
the top sometimes. I don't know if we take 10% off. >> And
Kimmy would just not stream for a while and people would forget
about it and Paul would be like, "Yeah, and whatever. Her wasn't
even that good." And people would move on. But because the roles
are this way, people are like, "She did what? Oh my god, what
a
Did you hear that? Did you hear what Kimmy did? Oh my god, dude.
That was so long ago." Yes, I knew about it. It was a long time
ago. It was a long time ago. The details. Ew. I don't want to
hear them. the details. Please, dear Lord, please. I don't want
to hear the details. Happened a long time ago. Is Paul a victim?
No. Paul has done a million worse things. Stop treating Ice Poseidon
like he is a victim. He is not. >> I would just like more
people to leak these things, right? Cuz I do get it. The I think
the worst thing Hannah talks about here, cuz we watched this
last night. This is just for you guys who are early stream viewers,
okay? You guys weren't here at like 3:00 a.m. last night watching
this with us. All right. She leaks eventually. She'll get to
it. Okay. That
the reason they were split up, the reason they were on break
was because Paul cheated on Kimmy.
Right. So, the reason she was living with uh Gunnar and Coupot
and all these people apparently, I believe according to Hannah
was that Paul had cheated on Paul had cheated on Kimmy and Kimmy
split. Yeah. I So I'm like, dude, how could you be mad that when
you were split because you cheated on her? She just said that
15 seconds ago. Oh, I'm not listening to her right now. Sorry.
I watched the whole thing last night. Okay, I know it's all in
my head. Amumu, so maybe she did tell you that. Okay, >> way
worse things. >> I want more leaks of what the calls are.
Okay, I want more. >> Million times worse. Million million
million. I just cannot believe the first 20 minutes of his stream,
him sitting there like this,
purple all around his eyes, sitting there like live in the chat.
What's up, guys? I tr I will never trust anyone again. Never
again.
>> Dude, that was so crazy. I don't know, guys. I don't
know if I'll ever be able to trust another human being again.
It's like, okay, come come on, man. >> I can't believe
this was done to me. I can't I am such a good person.
I help so many people. Paul, who? Who? Paul, who? Name one person.
Who? Who? Who?
Who? Who? Honda? I mean, Tamman for sure. Didn't Tam get like
100K? >> Name one other person. Who? How was he the victim?
I don't understand. I'm not grasping it. Explain to me, >> guys.
I don't care what Hannah's saying. She is Kimberly's friend,
so obviously she's going to take Kimberly side. Hannah is living
in California. Does she >> Paul didn't know.
My god, Paul, I hope you're feeling okay. Poor Paul.
Oh, this is awesome though that this guy's going to interlace
cuz they were reacting to each other, right? Paul clearly had
her on off stream, right, on a second monitor and she was like
reacting to things that were getting said in his chat cuz his
chat was coming to her chat and saying the things that he was
saying. >> It was miscommunication. Do you know how many
people have said DM'd me? It's hard to track last night. It was
miscommunication in their relationship. >> Was she supposed
to say the details?
>> Yeah, his huge it rammed into it. We were in his tiny
little mattress with all the trash surrounding him. It was nasty.
But I >> uh So this was this is key misinformation from
Lav. Very bad. Lav does lie sometimes. Okay. There wasn't even
a mattress there. Gunnar tried to correct this.
But Lav lied. Okay. There was There wasn't even a mattress. All
right. There wasn't It was just blankets on the floor, dude.
It was just blankets on the [__] floor. >> But
I went in there. I went in there every other night. I couldn't
get enough. Was she supposed to say the details? I don't understand.
He knew. That's That's the point I'm trying to make. Paul knew.
Stop treating him like he's a victim. Paul knew. Paul knew. Paul
knew. Like, I understand. Kimmy's probably done things. I understand.
Kimmy's probably treated girls the way they shouldn't be treated.
Let's take this as a moment where we should all treat everyone
with respect and peace. But he's not a victim.
He's not a victim. He's not.
He's not. I mean, >> I don't trust anyone.
I don't trust anyone. Did >> Did this person get like a
theater degree or something? Like a drama degree? Cuz like all
of the reactions are really It's very funny. I enjoyed watching
the stream. Okay. >> Okay. Paul ice postiden. Okay. Ice
Poseidon. Poor guy.
He didn't know Paul cheated on her. They broke up. They were
living separately for a long time. I don't know. She just lives
at 200% volume time. But during that time, I know for a fact
they were both other people. Many other people. Both of them.
Both of them. This doesn't mean that we should all turn into
villains. Okay? This doesn't mean that we shouldn't be the hero.
If you see something wrong, say something and do something. >> It's
funny watching a psycho girl that got popular from their boyfriend
scream about and defend another girl that got popular from their
boyfriend. Calm down, >> I will say she's got a racket
going. Okay. She criticized Ice Poseidon and then all the IP
or sorry, all the CX chatters come over and start giving her
donations to criticize her.
What a racket, dude. I need to get in on this.
>> Thank you.
Thank you. Okay, if you're saying that, you can go ahead and
go watch Sam Pepper. Go to his stream. Go watch him and his turn.
I don't give a I'm saying what I believe in and what I have seen
with my own eyes. Obviously, this isn't good for them. But Paul
not standing on his ground defending his woman. But I know for
a fact he's going to be back with her, >> that's horrible.
>> Yes. Yes. >> That's your girl. That's the girl
you've >> Didn't we watch this yesterday? Yeah. Evil Johnny
Bravo. But not everybody watches all 12 hours of the stream.
Okay. So, I'm I'm recapping for everybody. We're just watching
a quick recap of this. But that Hannah just hit the key point.
Okay. Ice Poseidon can act like this if he actually breaks up.
If he if he gets back together with Kimmy, all right, that's
the the biggest move at this point. Okay, you you can't say you're
humiliated and all this when Gunnar and Lab talk about your girlfriend.
Okay, like Gunnar didn't really talk about Ice Besidon at all.
He kind of just [__] on on Kimmy. Ice totally goes
to his Discord. He says, "This is all this Gunnar humiliated
me by Kimmy." Doesn't defend her at all. doesn't say anything
in her favor at all. If you get back together with her now, you're
you are admitting you are entirely in the wrong. You are entirely
in the wrong if you get back in back together with her, right?
And you wouldn't stand up for her. It's embarrassing. I I thought
this was her best point. It's like, dude, if you get back together
with her now and you wouldn't stand on business and defend your
girl at all, yeah, kill yourself. You You suck in a video game.
That's just a joke. We obviously don't want Paul to hurt himself.
We love Paul, okay?
We love you, Paul. We don't want anything bad to happen to you.
with and you've loved for eight years on and off whatever the
years you people that's your woman that's your partner and you're
not going to defend her when goon says to the stream oh I girl
you're going to sit there and tell everyone you didn't know you're
going to make Kimmy look like a psycho b that cheated on you
not going to stand on and then Kimmy not saying anything not
going live not standing her ground what
that's not chill stand your ground both of you say the truth
that's what drives me insane Timmy, say something. Say something.
She's so scared of you, Paul. That she's not going to say anything
cuz you're a psychopath. I don't understand how people were like,
"Oh my god, poor Paul. Oh my god, poor Paul." Goon and love.
They both >> Okay. I I Why did they include that in the
edit? Love. Goon and love.
I'm surprised she didn't say Gwen and Love. >> No matter
how cynical they are, they both have each other's back. They
are a team. They're standing their ground. They have each other's
back. That's how you're supposed to be as a couple. Paul, you
acting like you didn't know about Kimmy. Saying to your stream,
"Oh, I just told I just told Kimmy I dumped her. I just told
Kimmy we're done." What kind of a man is that? Say to your stream,
"Man up." Oh, yeah. I knew. But I love Kimmy and we're together
now.
My god. Put your ego to the side for 2 seconds. But I don't think
you can. That's not possible. >> Ice is right for dumping
her. Imagine finding out your future wife got with some loser
hours after meeting him when it took you months literally for
the streets. W >> I Okay, that one that one's tough. That
one's tough to stand on business on. Okay, that would be pretty
rough. I I feel like cuz apparently there's this whole lore where
Ice was like chasing this girl and trying to get her to sleep
with him for a long time. That would be a rough one. Okay, I
have like a tiny bit of sympathy there. You still got to stay
on business, but as a little bit that feels bad. Okay, that's
definitely >> Paul has known. Paul has known. I don't give
a Paul has known. Did you see what happened on my birthday, June
28th? Did anyone see what happened on everyone's streams in Miami?
Everyone suddenly stopped partying because they were afraid of
Paul. The my entire birthday, Kimmy was in her bedroom in the
Airbnb that she paid $700 for for this tiny bedroom. She was
in her bedroom the entire time crying because she was afraid
of Paul my entire birthday. >> Question. How do you know
Paul knew? His whole reaction to everything indicates
>> Because I know he knew. Kimmy told me a lot years ago
that Paul knew. >> And it's saying I'm not a victim. Sure
>> Feel power.
>> Hannah is somebody that I tried to get Kimberly to stop
being friends with that insane.
Uh
completely
completely deal. I mean you should ask Hannah about Fuzzy and
and >> Oh yes. Apparently, apparently Ice Beside leaked
that Hannah Boozy tweeted no. He's just on Kimmy again. Again,
all of the [__] on Kimmy directly. It's like if you
get back together with her, you look like a total piece of [__]
now. Just so you know, you look like a complete piece of you
know what I mean? I mean, all these people live in houses. So
Hannah is completely
Hannah only knows what Kimberly tells her. Okay. And Kimberly
said the same to Lav and Goon. So
like what are we talking about here? Anna, another 30-year-old
person who's never accomplished anything in her entire life.
>> No surprise. You see a pattern here. >> I mean,
like, come on. I mean, yeah, it makes sense, though. A crazy
woman like >> Ah, man. It feels I don't want to go after
Ice cuz I I do think Ice is like a good streamer, but man, it's
like, dude, you're playing Plinko right now at like 3:00 a.m.
I don't know, dude. I don't know. I don't know. I'm rich, so
I'm right. That's where he's coming from. He's like, "I did something
great because I'm rich." It's like, you can actually get rich
doing pretty
nowadays. I don't know if you know this, you just sell. You can
just gamble on stream as somebody popular. Okay?
It doesn't You don't have to be really smart. You don't have
to be really skilled. You don't have to better the world in some
way at all. And you could be really rich. >> Attacking
me, the guy who was a victim in the situation. She is a crazy
woman. Crazy women always attack the guy. Of course, they never
think they do anything wrong. I mean, Hannah should be grateful.
I'm the reason she ever has any content. >> I just want
to point out that Ice Poseidon is doing a
3:00 a.m. depression stream playing while venting about his relationship.
He's like one bowl of curry away from just being Darius. Okay,
that's it. Is almost nothing separating them anymore. >> You
know, everything she reacts to is in my community. Her entire
content is revolved around my >> Curry. Yeah, the joke
is that Darius is Indian. That's the joke. Yeah, Curry. Yeah,
the joke is that Darius is Indian. >> Community. The very
first time that something happened that made me question
all of the type of person Kimberly was that changed my opinion
on who I thought she was was uh like the first time we broke
up, dude. Like four years ago when we were both single. Nah,
Ice is actually funny. Darius is funny. Okay. Darius is extremely
good at going with the flow. All right. He's very good at going
with the flow and being funny in the moment. Okay, you guys can
hate him all you like. Darius is very capable of being funny
in a similar way to Ice. Ice just happened to get in on the ground
floor. All right, what is this? What is this? What is this? Hold
on.
Why did you just link this portal? This is totally unrelated
to anything we're doing today. Sorry, I just got I I just Okay.
Uh, thank you. Uh, okay. All right. All right. Sorry. We could
That's very off topic. It's very out of nowhere >> time
we broke up, dude. Like >> here, I'm going to I'm going
to back it up a little bit. We'll let him keep >> That
made me question
all of the type of person Kimberly was that changed my opinion
on who I thought she was was like the first time we broke up,
dude. Like four years ago when we were both single, she texted
me randomly one time when I was in Florida
and she said, you know, I miss you. I want to see you. you know,
if you come and uh and see me like she was in LA at an Airbnb
and she was just like, "I miss you. Can you come see me?" Like
blah blah blah. And I'm like, "Uh,
>> no, you know, I don't really want to, you know." And
then she's like, "Please, I miss you." And all this stuff. I'm
like, "Well, you know, I guess if you really want to see me,
you know, I could I like I could be interested in talking about
things."
>> So, I flew 6 hours from Florida all the way to LA. And
then when I got there, >> wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
So, hold on. The start of the story is well I told her no I don't
want to come see you. So anyway after like twisting my rubber
arm I flew to LA immediately.
How do you make yourself sound good at that? How do you try to
do that? Yeah. I told her no. Obviously I don't want to see you.
So anyway 5 minutes later I flew to LA there. She treated me
like dirt and she treated me like like I would try to be flirty
or whatever touchy and be like what are you doing? I'm like what
like what are you talking about? She's like we're just friends.
Like you like don't do that. And I'm like, "You
said that you miss me and you want to see me and like you said
you said things that are like make me think that I that you want
to rekindle stuff." And she said, "No, I I just wanted to see
you as a friend."
And I was like, >> "Okay, that's if that's true, that's
actually up." Who did he fly to? Ice flew to Kimmy. Kimmy was
in LA. He was in Florida. She said, "Hey, I miss you. Can we
come? Can we hang out? You want to come here?" That's That's
up. Okay, that's that's pretty [__] up. >> Are
you Are you kidding me? I just flew 6 hours. You wanted me to
fly 6 hours to just see you as a friend? And like she had me
sleep in the same bed with her as well, but like with a barrier
of pillows between us and I'm like, "What going on?" And then
I realized
um there was two of her friends that were staying with her in
the Airbnb that were just big fans of me and they just really
wanted to meet me. That was it. like >> she made it. >> Oh,
that's
Oh, that would feel pretty up. I would need a little more proof
of what was going on there. I mean, she clearly had feelings
for him. They got back together, right? I don't totally believe
I don't totally believe that she just didn't want to. I'm guessing
something else happened, right? I'm sorry. I don't really believe
that that she said, "Hey, come see me. I miss you." And it was
just introduced to friends. I I feel like there's got to be more
to that story that she could fill in there. ed me to fly across
the country for the real reason being that her friends were fans
of me. That was it. And I had to figure that out on my own with
context clues of the moment I showed up. They were like, "Yo,
hey, I'm a big fan." And like all the I'm like I'm like what
the So I mean, I should have known the type of person she was
at that point. That was my very first time where I was like
up like I'm glad I just spent, you know, $500 on a flight, flew
six hours for nothing and I ended up leaving that day. I went
there for not even a day. I left that day cuz I'm like, what
am I doing here? And then I texted her very upset. I'm like,
this was bull. How dare you? Why would you do that? And then
she would say,
she actually said a text, I don't know how to how I feel. I'm
sorry. I don't know how to feel. >> So, I just want to
point out that somehow I has somehow moved like all of the negative
emotions he he feels towards Kimmy, which I just feel kind of
bad about. Okay, that I understand a lot of people here don't
like Kimmy. Okay, some people don't like Kimmy, but like literally
Lav and Goon are the people who clowned on him and somehow he's
like now transferred all of his negative negative emotions onto
Kimmy. And I don't even think he feels that angry at like Lav
and Goon anymore. I'm not even joking. I'm not sure that like
if you guys lay low, which you're not at all by the way, all
you would have to do is like lay low and just let him come to
his senses and he would totally forgive you. But if you keep
going and taunting him, he's probably not going to. Okay.
He's like transferred all of his negative feelings onto Kimmy
somehow. >> It's like, okay, so I flew back to Texas
after you just friend-zoned me heavily for after baiting me there.
>> Sorry. Extorase got you exactly, Lav. I love Kimmy.
Sad face. Lol.
Laugh. Laugh thinks she's so funny typing that out. I love Kimmy.
I love Kimmy. She thinks she's so funny typing that. And then
but when I get back to Texas, you're like, I don't know how I
feel. Like, what does that mean? So now you're re re she's re
going back to the the baiting of like pretending that she wanted
to rekindle stuff. >> And then I said, "What do you mean?
You know, you don't know how to feel. I'm sorry." She's like,
"I'm sorry you misinterpreted." Then like the next message is
like, "I'm sorry you misinterpreted this. You know, I just want
to be friends." And I'm like, like every message is a completely
different
intention. Like what are you talking about? I mean, trust me,
I I've done I've done stuff that's not right in relationships
or in my relationship with her for sure, but it's all dude to
I that I deal with, you know? It's like not for no reason. It's
like you I get you get with so much that it makes me do like
I don't know like I don't know have you guys ever you know what
I'm talking about? Like I don't have you ever dealt with that.
It's like you get pushed past a certain point of likeing with
your head so much that you end up doing stuff that is totally
out of your character. It's like >> no I can't imagine
this. What? I think physical abuse leak is coming. What? No,
I don't think so. He He's saying he's does [__] that's
totally out of his character. I'm imagining this is emotional
stuff. I don't think this just me personally. I don't think Ice
is a physical kind of guy. I don't think he does physical stuff,
right? Like I don't think he gets physically abusive. I just
>> episode from Spongebob with Patrick and
Manta Ray guy like villain guy. It's like is this your wallet
or like whatever? Or is this your your picture in your wallet?
Yeah. Is this whatever in your wallet? Yeah. So, this must be
your wallet. Nope. It's just It's like what? I lay I lay out
all the all the facts. You agree with all the facts. I put it
all together and then nope, it's wrong. Like, what are we talking
about here? And it's aggravating cuz some of those conversations
last, you know, two, three hours and it's just a waste of time
at the end of it. It never cuz it's like it just doesn't go anywhere.
This program was made possible by contributions from >> So
that is all of the preceding stream content before we get to
this morning early la late last night after his stream early
this morning. Now some people believe this is because he clicked
on a certain tweet and then he started crashing out. Okay. Some
people have led me to believe I I
I basically mean people in Ice Besidon's Discord. Okay. that
he he clicked on a certain tweet which might be it might just
be this tweet. Okay, he might have clicked on this tweet and
then he kind of started like uh losing it in his Discord. It
was a short amount of time after this. All right. Kind of lost
it in his Discord a little bit. All right.
>> We put the song out. The song's a hit. Okay. It's It's
spreading like wildfire through the CX community. Okay,
we're So, you might have clicked on this song and and gone off
a little bit. We'll We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see.
We'll see. We need to read the actual logs. Okay. Someone we
recognize here. Cheese Beef. This guy was in the chat last night.
Maybe he'll be in the chat again today at 1:27 a.m. Pacific.
So, this would be 4:27 Eastern in Miami. Probably 4:27. I think
Ice said he knew they but didn't know the extent of it aka the
mattress. How many years has Ice talked about needing a woman
of high class as who he chooses to marry? This guy this guy is
a top tier troll by the way. Is Ice mad because she didn't tell
him goon didn't have a mattress? Well, I think he says I don't
know the extent of it. I don't exactly know what he means. Okay.
Pens of goat. I don't know what he means.
That could mean anything. All right. Well, besides the obvious
hoe and low class setting and behavior, I didn't know they dated
or she had feelings for him or any of that. I thought they might
have had a thing as roommates through context clues, but I didn't
know they cared for each other and how long it went on for. When
I asked if she had anything with him, she said no. And basically
anything towards him was meaningless and basically nothing.
Oh, okay. That's a that's a strong claim that he asked was there
anything with Gunnar and she said no. I would say that's that
would be like a lie. like a straight up lie. You either say I
don't want to talk about it or you don't say anything or you
either say I don't want to talk about it or you tell the truth.
Don't do Don't lie. Okay. You say I don't want to talk about
it. You tell the truth or
Well, there is no other or it's Yeah, basically nothing. That's
Yeah, that's just not true. Don't lie. Don't lie. Lying is bad.
Also, Kimberly saying we will stay together. No, we are not.
These are all bottom to top these ones. Okay, let's keep going.
I spent 6 hours speaking with her to try to get everything and
some closure and she couldn't even admit to me she lied.
So that I've always given her the benefit of the doubt from past
that was bad and I truly believed she may have been naive or
unknowingly hurting me or unknowing and hurting me. But this
situation is impossible to be naive about. So I assume all other
situations she wasn't unaware of either now uh either now. Okay.
The thing that hurts me the most is she has no money at all and
she has to pay her expensive rent on her own now. So I know 100%
she will be with another guy within the week. But whatever she
she's basically screwed living in LA. Yeah, this is this is financially
dependent on me and she's now I read that as something as in
romantic feelings not hooking up. I don't view Kimmy uh that
as Kimmy lying.
Okay, maybe cuz it seemed like she said that something happened,
right? There's a thing as roommates through context clues. When
I asked if she had anything with him, she said no. And anything
towards him was meaningless and basically nothing.
Yeah. I mean, we just have to see what the actual context of
the messages is, right? You just have to see that cuz you you
really don't know. True, but who is the guy who's that guy going
to be? Random dating app person. I don't know. Anyone who will
support her. The moment I stopped paying rent, which was last
month, she really pushed the moving in together thing. So, yeah,
I know she was just I know she just has no money. all year. Never
talked about moving in. But now we now wants to. Lol. She's going
to be used and abused in LA by dudes who will lie to her. Lol.
She's unfortunately. But it makes me feel bad. But I Nothing
I can do. It's crazy. She had it made. She had her own room,
was going to buy a pink Tesla that she said she wanted, and all
of this nice stuff, but she messed it all up. Now she can go
back to on floor mattresses like a low class. This is just venting.
This is just venting more. it. This is just all getting way way
way way more embarrassing if he gets back together with her,
right? Like, it's already embarrassing. I wouldn't I don't think
you should vent like this about a former partner anyway, right?
Even if you're mad in public, you can vent to friends or whatever,
but in venting in public, like a public Discord like this, these
are all messages from his Discord. It's kind of goofy. It just
looks bad, okay? Just looks bad. And it looks it looks 10 times
worse if you get back together. Okay, they'll be back together
within a week. This is what many people are saying is they're
they're about to be back together like within a week, within
a month, they'll be back together. He's not going to get back
together with her, bro. Okay. I don't know about that, man. I
don't know. Would not be surprised, but the ice angle would have
to be beyond fried. Okay. Uh she let this drive my car when they
were together. She has to borrow a car sometimes to drive. And
I said, "Okay, only if you drive it." Like, bruh, she's disrespectful
as hell. Also, Kim tried to prevent every single girl streamer
from coming on to any of my streams or events. Murk, I wouldn't
touch you with a 10-ft pole. Oh, this was a MK.
Sorry, that's just out of nowhere. He says, "Murk, I wouldn't
touch you with a 10-ft pole." Kind of [__] up. Okay.
What the hell? Merk's cool, bro. What What do you What you say
that for, dude? 20 foot.
Sorry. I You're right, Cherry. You're You're right. When you're
right, you're right. It was a 20 foot pole. My bad.
Important to be accurate when we were reading these. She's being
a troll a little bit. I didn't read. So, I tried to get all the
context messages, all the like contextually important messages,
but I didn't read that one enough to know I should go grab whatever
merc messages were there. When have I ever been wrong? Hard to
come up with a specific time right now, but there have been times.
I know it for a fact. I'll never say you were never wrong, but
can't come up with something specific right now. Also, can't
come up with a time Lav lied except that one time about the mattress.
But other than that, shut the [__] shut up. Isn't
this Isn't this message she said crazy now with everything that's
happened? pretty hypocritical.
I didn't pass it. Damn, traffic must have picked it up. Must
have picked up. I'm just mad at you. How embarrassing. If we
date again, all the girls are going to be like, "Oh, he wanted
me and when he when they broke up and I didn't want him." They'll
think they have won over on me. Especially because you talked
bad about me to some of them and some of them I don't like. So
rude and hurtful.
So this is uh
Wait, but Kimmy, hold on. Gunnar didn't even leak any [__]
that Kimmy said about you.
That's actually not the same. He's saying, "Isn't this up now?
Oh, you talked me to all these people." Doesn't sound like Kimmy
talked him to anybody. It sounds like, right? Am I crazy? It
sounds like she just This guy. This wouldn't be the same at all.
Unless I'm misreading the sides. This can't be Ice, right? This
has got to be ice on this side. This is This is his side. Yeah.
Yeah. I would also never check her phone, but she always checks
mine. Yes. She had a guilty conscience.
Okay. I don't know if that's what that means. Let's be real.
I would just say, "Okay, hold on. Who's cheated on who and how
many times is probably what I would ask, right? Who's cheated
on who and how many times? Is there a reason for that distrust
or is there no reason for that distrust?" Let's be real. Ice
will never get over her. She's going to tell him all the things
he wants to hear, but in her mind, she will think the same and
think you are wrong.
Um, she's never told me anything I've ever wanted I wanted to
hear ever. She always says, "I'm the bad guy." at Ice Boseidon69.
Honestly, just throw yourself at work. Message Eddie for another
100 day challenge. Make that bread, baby. Uh, not in a place
to do that. He is. He is. Guys, should we Hold on. You know what?
We actually should have the music for this, shouldn't we? Now
that I think about it. Hold on. We should have this going. It's
just the right soundtrack. Okay, I'm sorry. It is
not in a place to do that right now. It's going to take me a
while to overcome this when the event is over.
Okay, that's way too loud though. Holy [__] There
we go. At Ice Poseidon, explain this. Kimberly argues with Ice
Boseidon after he takes her phone. Oh, hold on. I didn't grab
that [__] Hold on. Uh, am I in I'm not in Discord.
Somebody just pointed out I'm not in the Discord. Let's pull
this up. Also, so he just said he didn't take her phone and apparently
he might have. Hold on. Let me find this video. Oh, did I just
kill my music? Whoops.
Let me see. >> What happens here? >> I did >> the
normal Wi-Fi. >> Yes, I did. Paul, >> the normal
Wi-Fi. >> Yes, Paul. The Wi-Fi in the house. >> The
good Wi-Fi. >> Okay. What are we doing here? What is >> Were
you not in here a second ago? You weren't right. >> I wasn't.
No. Sorry, I just joined cuz uh you asked. I just realized I
had my Discord mic muted. Yeah, I wasn't. I wasn't. You're right.
>> Okay.
What are you listen What is this music you're listening? >> I
put on I put on the dramatic music for ice beside log reading.
Okay. the appropriate appropriate music for hearing what a victim
he is from him himself. Okay, it just is. >> What did I
miss? What What have we gone
>> Uh, not that much. We went over all the Hannah stuff
from last night. So, this Hannah Rididgeway person, former partner
of Sam Pepper, okay, former I think ex-wife of Sam Pepper just
leaked some stuff about Ice, said he knew about Goonar and Kimmy
hooking up. And then Ice went and started talking about Kimmy,
leaked some there, and then he went off in his Discord. Okay.
So, he's talking all kinds of his Discord. We're not all the
way through this stuff yet, though. We just went So, he he basically
just said, "She always looked through my phone. I never looked
through hers." And then this video got posted. Somebody asked
Yeah, somebody asked, "Wait, what's this all about?" Kimberly
argues with ice after he takes her phone. >> I got it.
Don't worry. >> Also, just give me two seconds. You're
here now, but I'm uh I'm going to be right back. I got to use
the bathroom. Get some water. >> I'm going to let this
play. Well, >> why don't >> He's not afraid of black
people, by the way. My >> phone's dead. I told you. Yeah,
but >> Well, I can't use your phone to rech. >> No,
you can, but I like want to read it, >> Well, just focus
on the slots, dude. When my phone charges, then then we're
Nah. Look at how anxious she is, bro.
dude.
Dude, no shot, dude. She looks like the [__] defendant
after a judge is reading the [__] conviction for
a triple homicide, bro. She's like [__] sweating
bullets. [__] nah. She just took like a pill bottle
worth of Adderall, though. She's like
nails.
Nails.
>> Oh [__] Zero chance. >> Hey, guilty.
Hey, I' I'd never seen something more guilty. >> 100%.
I'm not going to lie to you. He wouldn't even have to find a
thing. You run back the VOD, it's over. It's raps. >> It
doesn't matter. >> He He He could She could be crystal
clean. She's not clean. You feel me? >> I was going to
say just from the audio, by the way. I had walked away. All I
had was the audio. Also, Kenny, thank for the raid. All I had
was the audio and I was like, "Dude, she sounds like she is not
good with him having that phone." I might have to I got to write
back a little bit. Okay. Cuz I was only >> Yeah. I got
to see. I got to see. >> I got
>> it was It was um Well, I want to read it, too. It's
like, oh, you don't want that phone out of your sight. You don't
You don't want that vote out of your sight right now. >> My
phone's dead. I told you. >> Yeah, but >> Well, I
can't use your phone to read >> No, you can, but I like
want to read it, >> Well, just focus on the slots, dude.
>> When my phone charges, then then we're
>> dude. The camera guy's [__] her over. The
camera guy's [__] her over. The camera guy keeps
moving it, so she's like craning her neck and leaning in to try
to get it trying to get a view. Okay, the camera guy is [__]
her here. What the [__] >> There's no shot.
No shot. >> I just know something is up. And now seeing
how she reacts from this.
Oh, yes. Okay. >> Okay. Okay. >> Listen, extora,
I understand we're like reading into it, but to me when I heard
like No, no, no. I just want to look as well. I just want to
keep like my eyes on I I immediately >> was the stuttering.
It was the stuttering. It was the I'm not going to lie to you.
The stuttering people are >> It was very anxious. It was
a lot of anxiety. Okay. A lot of anxiety.
>> That's all I heard. I felt it. I could feel it. Okay.
The flag went up. The flag went up. I could I could sense something
was wrong. All right. >> We could sense it. >> Do
you think? >> Okay. The vibes are just bad up. >> The
vibes are bad for what? What you mean? What? Because I need to
I want to read the chat on your phone for 5 minutes while my
phone charges. >> You were bad vibes for a second. So,
let's just >> What did I do? >> Before I gamble money.
>> The [__] did I do? How my bad vibes? I was
just trying to get your phone so I can read the chat. >> Don't
look at me like that. >> I'm not What are you talking about?
>> Here's your phone if you want. >> Bro, just chill.
Let me use your phone. >> Dude, for a second there. Hold
on. I just I had a weird thought that like he just turned a black
light on or something. I thought we were going to see some crazy.
I just The light went blue and I I like I started like laughing
at the idea. I thought, man, thank God. They're in a hotel. Okay.
>> Why you're talking to me right now? >> I'm not
doing [__] I'm not doing >> Okay. Check your
enabling money.
>> I'm not doing anything. I'm literally just standing
here asking to use your phone to read the chat room, dude. >> Yes,
you can, but just stop being rude. >> I'm not doing anything.
You're the one being [__] rude. Like, come on, dude.
What the Like, you win four grand. You're being like, I'm not
doing [__] All right. So, what you going to do now?
You should act like he sees something on the phone and say
>> I don't know how you how would you do it if you could
feel the tension in the room. Dude, the person editing this is
like edoralizing a lot. But
>> I'm trying to think of how you do that. Wait, what is
this? >> Wait, who is this texting you? >> Yeah,
I Wait, who's this texting?
>> So funny.
>> I hate gamblers.
I know. I hate gamblers. I don't even hate gamblers, but like
I like I like the concept of gambling. Like I I like gambling
is fun. I don't know. I think the concept of promoting gambling
is probably evil. I think there's just no way to get around it.
I got >> I I completely agree. I completely agree. But
um the the thing that pisses me off is when people do like, "Yeah,
dude. You know, I'm just you know, this is my slot. Like you
know, I'm I'm putting heat out right now." So you're not doing
You're pushing a button, bro. You're pushing a button and a literal
calculator is giving you money or taking it away from you. You're
not doing
>> you are literally doing nothing. He's like, I'm I'm
on a heater, bro. You ain't on You're not on anything. All right,
dude. It pisses me off. I hate >> Man, I
I totally disagree. I think like the vibes the vibes are right.
Okay, I I like it. I just if you weren't losing money, the the
thing that gets me is people like losing their mortgages. Okay,
that's what [__] me up. If you want to just spend
like a couple hundred bucks and you want to around and have that
feeling, it's okay to me. But it's not, dude. And also promoting
it. I got a I got a message from stake, okay? An actual stake
like affiliate thing. They're like, "Hey, we want you to like
stream steak." And I'm like, "Nope.
No thank you."
>> And I I wouldn't mind like the money would probably
be insane, but I just I can't right now, man. [__]
>> Gambling money is stupid money. But yeah, it's I I agree
with you. It's unethical. I can't. It's unconscionable. >> I
I would think about it if they just gave me one to gamble without
the need to if I didn't have like an affiliate deal, but like
I think they're just offering affiliate deals. And there's no
do an affiliate deal where it's like I make money based on how
many people actually sign up. That's uh that's like all of the
wrong incentives to me. >> I
would maybe do it if it was like an exclusive like hard blocked
poker only site. I think something like that where poker to me
has enough skill put into it that I could say that like it's
it's it's just like a game with money. Like that's that's the
way I would. So I I feel comfortable with something like poker.
Like poker is my line. Pretty much every all other gambling I
find totally and entirely unacceptable. >> I I know that
slots are bad. I know slots are going to take my money over the
long term, right? Like I know that. But I still think slots are
fun. Like I think they're fun. I just don't do them in like online
or I just don't do it. It's like occasionally if I go to like
a bar and somebody wants to do it. I'll I'll like ah
>> hit some slots. You going to hit some >> We'll
let the VLT I'll throw 20 bucks >> Nest was right about
you, bro. Destiny was right about you. Come on. >> All right.
Fair enough. Fair enough. Seems appropriate reaction.
>> Appropriate reaction. Um I think slots are so fun. I
don't know. Le Bandit's so fun to me. Le Bandit watching >> Leand
Leandit is crazy, bro. Le Bandit is so fun to watch. >> It's
Yeah, Wes said he's making 70K from some deal he's getting from
having like 200 viewers. Well, also
also Wes fulfills his affiliate programs like really well. Wes
Wes, what do you call it? Um, he fulfills like basically
he gets lots of signups, he gets lots of people putting money
in. It's uh it it just works for him. Okay,
please stop talking about Okay. Well, I didn't know you were
still here, Lav. All right, we'll we'll move on. Well, we'll
watch Kimmy Gamble, I guess. Let's continue on with this. I want
to watch the rest of this cuz I I have to see where this >> Oh,
is Lav here? Lav, I hate you, but what you did to Ice was funny.
>> And same with your husband. What you guys both did was
funny. W >> How much did you put in? >> 12,500. I
lost. Hey, can you pull chat up here so I can see you? >> No.
I'm going to use your phone for the rest of the night now. >> That's
fine. Can I use yours? >> This is uh this is tough,
>> dude. Wait, he kind of just laid his on the table. I'm
not going to lie to you. And it was huge, bro. It was huge. I'm
not going to lie. That's crazy, bro.
>> Hold on, though. Hold on, though. He's got to show the
trust the other way, right? He's got to go. You know what? Once
my phone charges, you can use my phone, right? >> Yeah.
You can use my phone. Yeah. 100%
for bed, baby. Let's go. We'll >> see. I'm going to let
I'm going to let my phone charge and I'm going to use your phone
for the rest of the night because I don't appreciate you being
>> You're being mean to me. Okay. >> I gamble for
you. >> No, this is your >> You're not going to give
me this money. I'm not >> Why not? I give my I give the
money to everyone else. >> I know, but you're not going
to give it to me.
>> All right. Well, I mean, now I won't. >> You You
weren't. >> I mean, I was, but now I'm not going to because
like, why would you say that stupid? Like, why would you say
such a stupid thing? >> Okay. Being honest here, I think,
unless something was cut out prior to the club, I don't think
he was being mean all the way up until she like was getting really
nervous and then like kind of poking at him. I don't think he
was being mean, but then he obviously like got very anxious and
edgy and then he got mean. So, unless something was cut out prior.
>> No, I I feel like that's true that he was he just wanted
to use like he wanted to use the phone to look at the chat and
>> Yeah. Her attitude was like, "Wait, why don't you want
me to have this phone?" And now he doesn't want to let it go.
So, I don't know. He's also Yeah, sure. Had he's like a little
immature himself. I don't know. We'll see. We'll see how the
rest of this goes. It's pretty ungrateful of you. I mean, I'm
not I mean, seriously, I'm just standing here. I'm not doing
anything. I just wanted to use your phone for chat. You're just
being an [__] >> No, I'm not. >> And
then now I'm just like, "All right, well, I'm going to let my
phone charge. Keep her in chat because >> Yeah, I said,
"Okay, can we pull up so I can see, too?" But it's okay. >> I
don't know what the hell's wrong with you, dude. Just >> Dude,
now I can just feel like this whole situation is just her face.
Her face right here is like the perfect
She looks at him like I know. I know everything's okay. She's
just like It's I don't know how to explain it. There's just something
I can tell the situation. It doesn't get any better from here.
Like everything everything's downhill. We're on a downward slope
now. >> I don't know the hell's wrong with you, dude. Just
keep going. >> This is 2023. July 2023. >> Can you
talk to me? >> I'm just >> Everything's [__]
up. Everybody in the room's depressed. What are we playing? Blinko.
It's time. >> I cannot tell you how much money I've watched
Darius right in front of me sink into this game. I I was screaming
at him of all the games on stake, do not play Plinko because
for some reason >> I I don't believe in it. I do not believe
in there's being specific games that are better than others.
But >> this is the lowest RTP game. >> I think this
RTP on Yeah, I think the >> No, Plinko's got the lowest
RTP. Plinko's got garbage RTP. What are you talking about? No,
it's not the highest. Shut the [__] up. It's There's
a 0% chance it's the highest. >> They were 100% baiting
you to say their name out loud. 100%.
>> Uh, true, true. But they they're around here all the
time. So, no. Plinko. Plinko is famously horrible RTP.
>> Say anything. >> Why you talk to me? >> I
don't want you to get mad at me. >> No, I'm not mad at
you. >> I mean, you seem mad at me. >> I I'm annoyed,
but I just I want to be having fun. Can you just be nice, >> I
am nice to you. I'm just standing >> Okay. Well, then let's
have fun. >> All right. I mean, then don't so don't be
weird then. >> Okay, then can I use your phone for chat
>> Well, then do you >> Yeah, I use my own phone.
I know. You know, you don't want me grabbing your phone. I get
it. >> No, you had it the whole time. I just >> Yeah,
barely. I had to [__] fight for >> No, I want
I want a phone, too. So, can I use yours? >> I gave you
your phone. I'm using mine. >> Oh. Oh, you want to use
my Oh, no. I'll use my phone. Wait, did I say I was going to
charge my phone and use yours? No, I'll use my phone. You can
use your phone. It's fine. >> Uh-oh.
That's all all that. That's massive loss right there. Okay. Massive
>> Yeah. Congratulations. I didn't do [__]
I don't care. >> 20x is good. >> I don't care what
anyone says. Say I'm not being a dick. Do [__] I
don't >> I'm a very stubborn person, but I know what I
do and what I don't do. I didn't do [__] I let nobody
tell me otherwise. >> Who likes this? Who likes this game?
This is the most boring [__] ever.
>> Okay. But the thing, if the streamer's watching, okay,
if they ever hit over on one of these right or left two, okay,
then they can pop the off. Right.
People hit the
>> I've seen some of people hit that. You've seen clips
of people who hit that. You never sit there and watch somebody
do it. But Leandanda is a journey. Okay. Every moment. >> Yeah.
Leand is always good. >> is a journey. >> Dude, the
bonus buys on Leandanda go so
>> Yeah, they do. >> Just this is just so like up
the vibes. This is such bad vibes. It's not fun. I just Let's
just have fun. >> Yeah.
If she put Le Bandit on the screen. Okay. They could turn the
whole night around. >> But instead, they're sitting here
>> Nobody wants to sit here while it's like >> I'm
having a great time. >> No, you're not. Just have fun.
Everything's
not, bro. >> What do you want me to do? I'm just standing
here watch I'm just standing here watching you. >> You're
upset. Let's just have fun. >> Okay, then why don't you
make me feel better, which you don't do and you don't know how
to do cuz you never do. >> just FYI. You want me to be
a good time after you put me down? Why don't you help bring me
back up? You never do that. That's You don't know how to do
>> So, go on.
Hey yo, what? Wait, what? What was that,
>> No, you're not a fan of that. Not a fan of that argument.
>> No, I'm not. Not at all. I'm not. >> Make me feel
better. I can't self
>> Oh, boy. >> Here. Do you want to play? >> I'll
just let you do it. >> No, I think you It's your turn.
>> No, it's just you do it. >> I think that I >> All right,
I'm just going to I'm just going to end the stream. >> No,
don't end the stream. >> I don't want so ridiculous. I
don't I just don't know. I don't want to like >> What is
wrong? >> Because I What do you mean? Okay. Okay. I'm going
to go outside. I'm going I'm going to let you sit here with the
camera. I'm going to go outside >> because like I'm just
going to take my situ myself out of the situation. I'll let you
take over the stream.
>> Because I don't want to be here. >> This is all
a bit dramatic.
This is all
>> I Okay, I'm not going to follow the situation cuz we're
not going to talk about it. But I feel like this thumbnail,
there's almost no way that's a quote. Okay.
I just can't imagine that's a quote from anything. All right.
I just I can't imagine it. I can't see it. I don't think so.
But all right. So, we're back to these logs. Ice Poseidon, explain
this.
41 more images.
Yeah, I remember. I knew I didn't do anything and she got mad
at me and said I was being mean. Lol. Okay. All right. Yeah,
the exact two years ago. It was the exact year she got weird.
Yep. She was finally fine before she was totally fine before
our first breakup and she supported me through a lot of hardships
and but then we got back to when we got back together. The second
time something about her changed.
Kick deal changed. It was before the kick deal. He says that's
crazy. It was before the kick deal but he's playing on stake.
That's kind of wild. Okay. Playing on stake without a deal. That's
[__] crazy.
Yep. She was totally fine before her first breakup and she supported
this. This one is what this guy's responding to. Seems like as
the years pass, you become the a better as a person and she becomes
worse and worse. I sincerely doubt that. >> Sincerely doubt
that. Yeah, sincerely doubt that. >> Blaze, bro. >> Yes,
she become she become a terrible human. Uh, and Ice leaks more
messages. This was 4 years ago. She has not changed. Only gotten
worse. Oh, so before your first breakup then? Well, surely that
surely doesn't make a lot of sense when I'm sitting here asking,
trying to listen, but you're not telling me. You man manipulate
people by acting stupid and doing things that suck. Then gaslight
them by getting angry. You pretend to have respect for people
you care about to lie to yourself about your morals. But when
do I do that? Can you give me an example? You do it all the time.
Lau. There's not There's not one example. It's just constant.
I can't tell if this is from Would these be would these be ice?
I thought these were ice before and now I'm not sure. These these
must be Kimmy, right? >> I have no idea. >> I can't
even tell. I can't even tell. I'm gonna assume that the the ones
in white are ice, right? Because it's from his phone. >> Yeah,
that's what I thought. And he's doing the search. That's weird
that he's the one doing the psych terms, gaslight, and stuff.
It's kind of just >> I mean, I guess that she didn't get
the white woman patch yet.
We'll wait it >> All right. The crazy part is the next
guy she gets with, she probably will move in with them, and that
will be confirmation on how fake she was.
She'll move in with another guy within the month. She's poor
and desperate to survive.
Gee's beef comes in. This honestly is starting to sound like
Kim is the one who had that had feelings for Goon and not the
other way around. I mean, why else keep up the lie for so long?
Ice responds, "Yes, Kim wanted to date and he didn't want to.
Then he wanted to and she didn't anymore or something. I don't
know. It's all pathetic."
Okay,
she's not in love with me. Lauo, she she don't know what love
is. Wait, when did he I don't even remember that line. I must
have read it. But the sad part is she probably wasn't in love
with you after the first breakup. She just wanted you to to use
you for your money. Yeah, I could tell something was different
the second time around. Somebody post the image on mod base ghost.
He's not modded. He says base ghost is somebody who is I think
is at least a kick mod for him. But in any case, Kimmy apparently
talks to this guy a lot. And then she talks to this guy. I don't
know. I don't know the base ghost lore. Okay. Other people know
it. I don't know it that well. Kim only dates men with no standards
from what I've noticed. When we were single, she tried to date
Mitch Jones before I told her she's a If she does, and I'll never
talk to her again if she does because that would be embarrassing.
Okay, we can all agree that Mitch Jones would be significantly
worse than Goon, right? That would be bad. >> Oh, yeah.
I mean, yeah, come on. >> I'm sorry. The Mitch >> Come
on. the Mitch. It's not even like
It's not even that Mitch Jones does bad, okay? It's not like
he's like an I don't even know if he's like an abusive partner
or anything. It's just like it's Mitch Jones. I'm sorry. It's
Mitch Jones. Like, have more self-respect.
>> I mean, there's no He He has no aura. Listen. I mean,
it's just >> it's tough. It's tough. >> You treat
her like garbo. Okay, I'll take your word for it. It's easy.
Didn't she do a stream with him while dating you? I think this
is Gooner that they're talking about here. Yeah, but don't worry
because she didn't like him anymore. But Maddie was banned from
any type of communication or stream time because I texted her
like three times when I was single. Lol.
And yes, Bass Ghost, I'm sorry. She actually called you short
and doesn't respect you either. Sorry, man. I took it back, but
it was true. That's just to the mud guy. Why did Why does anybody
even need to know this? Apparently, this base ghost guy is just
getting on. It doesn't seem like relevant information at all.
They keep bringing it up. Why?
Kimmy says, "I this is a Kimmy log from yesterday. I never cheated."
And Ice says, "She did." Chatter asks, "What's your proof and
what's your timeline? Are you talking about the U-Haul incident?"
And Ice responds, "She downloaded Hinge." And while I will agree
that that's bad, I do not think that necessarily equates to cheating.
Um, >> wait, while you're in a relationship? >> Well,
it depends on what when the timing was, I guess. And also, did
she download it? Did she add it? Or did she just leave it on
her phone? Uh oh. Yeah, that's a big difference because I I'm
not sure I don't I'm not sure. I've always deleted apps when
I >> if if she added it to her phone after they had a fight
or something, then I'm like, "Okay, you're you're uh Hinge deactivates
when you're not active." Okay. But was it active? Did you look
at the thing or do you just see the app >> Yeah, that's
a really big difference >> because she wasn't with the
guy. >> Yeah. Like I have, for instance, I have Hinge and
Tinder on my phone right now. I don't I don't think I've used
that in like a year. If I got into a relationship, I might not
even remember to delete it. >> Ooh, Dexter's posting more
logs from Kimmy. All right, hold on. I'm going to I'll pull these
up on the side here real quick. This is my Kimmy log album. Okay.
Okay.
I forgot I had this up from yesterday. My husband going sending
cucked mad. You can't do it. It can't be done. It literally cannot
be done.
>> You already lost, dude. >> You already lost. That's
rough. Okay. Ice says yes, it is cheating. All right, hold on.
I need to go look this up in my Discord really quickly. I >> I
would say it's under the umbrella of cheating is to if she actually
downloaded it. I would say that's under the umbrella. >> Yeah,
if she went if she went and added it then yeah, I would say for
sure it's um it's not good. It's not good at all. Okay. All right.
I got those extra logs. We'll we'll go through those the Kimmy
logs after we finish the Paul's logs from this morning. So Kim
only dates men with no standards. Well, at least that confirms
what Gunnar said about her only wanting to date streamers.
She will get only get lowass guys or young dudes who won't settle
down. So, he continues to leak logs after this. Hannah hates
Kim and is jealous of her. Friendship won't last. Everyone wants
a happy Kimmy. Thank you. I appreciate it. I want to be happy,
too. I'm working on it. Why do you not ever Why do you not ever
offer to help me pay for things? What? I do. Look at Instagram
for the latest example. Do you see? Yeah, I see. So, can you
take that back? Okay.
All right. This was uh as I was paying rent cuz uh somebody's
laughing at why don't you ever offer to help me pay for things.
Okay.
And let her use my card for Door Dash and whatever else she asked.
Okay. Because that really hurts me. I buy you stuff all the time,
but I guess it goes unappreciated. Okay. I don't want to hurt
you. I'm sorry. I'll take that as an acknowledgement that I do
offer to pay for things. Yeah, you do. And I don't want to fight.
I don't either, but I need you to let you know uh things that
are wrong so you can appreciate it. Thank you. Uh yeah, some
Yeah, but sometimes something you will get me h I don't know.
I don't know what the rest of that is. Continues leaking. That
was a response.
Yeah, but Oh, here you go. Sometimes you say you will get me
something and you get the appreciation for that and you never
get it though. True. I still pay for a lot though. When we are
together in person, you do. Yeah, it's fine. I don't want to
talk about it anymore. This is just a weird This is just weird.
That's all. That's just weird. >> What the [__]
is going on here? Yeah, it's I it's bizarre bizarre stuff she
started blaming. It is >> I just feel I feel better about
even like my worst relationships when I look at [__]
like this. >> I think you've just highlighted why people
find this compelling as content. Okay. Yes.
>> Makes him feel better. Started She started with blaming
me for wanting to sell pics to a viewer for money. That's weird.
All you care about is validation. You also lied. I never sent
pictures to that guy and now I wish I would have because you
said uh you said I did and I should have. I never sent pictures
to that guy. Now I wish I So this is him quoting gaslight. Intention
matters. No, those are my feelings and you would have if I didn't
catch you. I didn't. Okay.
>> Oh, blame me for wanting to sell. So she was going to
sell pics to a viewer for money. Okay. >> And
your favorite person's in the waiting room, by the way. I don't
know if you noticed this. >> Jesus Christ. I mean I I don't
I don't care. She's involved in the story. You know what I'm
saying? >> No. I mean I Yeah. No, no, no. It's I'm not
going to cut content like that, bro. I'm not gonna cut.
>> All right, that work. Boom. There it is. What's up,
lav? How's it going? >> Here. Hold on. I need to >> just
hang Just hang in. >> Yeah. Okay, we're reading some DMs
here. >> Yeah, this is >> What is the gaslight? Am
I Am I What is the gas light there? >> She said I never
sent pictures to the guy. Now I wish I had cuz apparently she
was going to send pictures. Oh, whoops. Wrong guy. me penguin
again. Here we go. Here we go. All right. Um, the gaslight is
see her saying like, um, because you said I sent pictures to
a fan for money. I wish I had. I wish I just made the money cuz
you and you're lying about me, right? So, they're having some
argument where she apparently offered or she was going to send
pictures to a viewer for money and then he caught it and was
like, "What the [__] Don't do that. >> Where's
your shirt?" >> Uh, remember this communication is between
people who are 30 years old. Does this not read like they're
13?
Uh, it could be like years ago, too,
>> No, that this is this was literally just a couple months
ago. >> These ones, the pictures to the viewer.
>> less idea >> because they just they fought about
it a month ago publicly. >> Unfortunate.
Okay. Uh, you guys, >> these people these people have been
together for like I guess almost a decade and they're they talked
to each other this impersonally. Isn't that strange? Isn't this
like the strangest conversation ever? Uh, it is a little weird
the way they talk to each other. >> After a decade of dating,
it's crazy. >> Ice has got pretty severe autism. I'm not
going to lie to you. This is what we've come to determine. All
right. >> I think they're both, but it's still just weird.
It like it it's just weird. It's weird. >> Okay, we all
Uh-oh. The Really Penguin and the Lav Penguin are very different
sizes. We just got the Really head and the Lav.
Wait, why do how did how did I get a
mysterious mysterious powers. That be >> Wait, what is
the penguin for? What What's the penguin meta? Quickly. Don't
tell her. Don't tell her. Don't tell >> I I Sorry. Why
do you need to know? >> Good cover. >> Why do you
need it? Good. >> I'm just curious. I think it's cute.
I just didn't know. >> Yeah, we're all penguins now. Although,
I am feeling a little weird without a shirt, so I have to >> Yeah.
What the Why'd you get naked? Hold on. There we go. Yeah, we're
back. We're back. We're good. We're good. All right. Money.
Sorry. This is very funny to me. Okay. Hannah, 199 results found.
Gaslight was like 20 results found. Money 260 results found.
Seems like something you might talk about a little bit. >> So
exhausting to log stuff like this about your partner. Like what
the are they even doing together if you have like logs of your
partner?
>> Well, I think I think probably he's just going back
and finding the stuff that's there, right? >> Yeah, but
like why you're like art artillery like against the like your
partner is so weird? Like >> why do you have why do you
have 200 photos of proof that like your partner mistreated you?
Like just break up. Just break up. >> Well, I think hold
on. I think he's literally searching for things to post right
now. That's still like scary. >> Yeah, I think probably
it probably to me doesn't make sense to like go grab [__]
from a long time ago to share with people on the internet, right?
>> I guess it does if you're completely isolated and lonely.
Like it he obviously like doesn't feel very close to a lot of
people, but it's still like just sad.
>> Well, I think he's one of those people >> airing
your out publicly like to some extent I think is kind of normal
for like a streamer couple, but doing like this like actual gay
ops on each other is gnarly.
Well, I don't think she's doing it on him, right? >> I
think he did. You not see the video of her threatening it that
she has logs of things and leaks? >> Wait, did you send
me that video or not? Did you send me the video or not? I literally
asked you for the video. Wait, what the >> Oh, no. It's
It was on It was I'm sure that someone has it and sent it to
you. He posted it last night of her a video of her saying that
she had leaks and
>> like while they were eating dinner. It was the straight
he was like he was recording her without her knowing. It was
It was weird. It was a weird video. >> Wait, I think that
was deleted from his logs. If somebody's got that, you got to
send it on. Okay. >> Hold on. Someone's got to send this
on. >> I can probably find it. >> Okay. All right.
I'm going to keep >> That's crazy.
>> We need that badly cuz I don't know when he posted that
exactly, but Jesus. Here, I'll check one thing here. Uh, is there
a purple army community? I'll see if somebody posts that in his
Twitter community real quick. How do you have them? Ask me one
of the mods. >> No, I haven't seen anybody post it in his
Twitter community. Geez. Okay,
>> we keep going. Then she said she wished I was like ABZ
because he pays for all his girls. Lol. Only >> Jesus Christ.
>> Uh, I know and I'm streaming, but I don't feel like
you should be making me feel this way with all the money you
have and everything we've been through. Maybe I'm just hurt because
the way I saw ABZ talk on stream about how he wanted his girl
to feel. And I wish you thought like that and wanted me to feel
that way. I do want you to feel the way the way he talked.
Okay, crazy. I'm not showing these to on her or to be a bad person.
I just know she will see this and really cares about viewer validation
so so much. I hope she can learn a thing or two from reading
everyone's responses so so she knows I'm not the only person
who thought she was in the wrong. Bro,
that's crazy to just go, you know what? Like I'm not doing this
to like [__] on her, but I just want you guys to
[__] on her and so she can see the viewers hate her
for this.
>> I think I think he's totally going crazy. I think that
she plays stupid or is really stupid and I think that he that
will drive someone crazy. Like he's he I think that's what he
means by gas lit. Like she must know what she's doing wrong,
but she's pretending she doesn't.
>> in the context of what that >> like just her behavior
like oh I didn't like I didn't know I was supposed to tell you
that I had sex with someone else. I didn't know I was supposed
to like not ask you for money. I don't know. I like I'm not doing
>> We haven't seen proof of that like how that conversation
went at all. I don't >> I'm saying from context clues that's
what I'm what like he even said in these I don't know if you've
read all of these logs. It's I think it's obvious that you haven't
yet. But he goes on to say like that she plays stupid and it
makes him feel crazy. >> Okay. Okay. That's fine. But like
the Hannah Ridgeway person went live last night and said that
she was sitting next to what? Sam Pepper. No, she was sitting
next to Ice and Sam called her and was like asking and talking
about the guy who talking about Gunnar talking about the guy
who Ice's girlfriend >> like like literally while she was
while he's on speaker phone with Ice and and her. Yeah. >> So
apparently she was saying that like he knows he's absolutely
known for a >> I just don't know how much they know either.
Like I don't know what the narrative is. Obviously, Kimmy has
given like them a different narrative to for self-preservation,
which like makes sense. So, it's possible that he like Ice did
not hear the version where like she blew him in in a U-Haul and
him on like a mattressless floor like >> Yeah. Yeah. I
We did not hear the U-Haul story on >> Yeah, I was about
to say Jesus Christ. >> Wait, what was he even U-Hauling?
Was it just the mattress in the standing desk
>> No, he No, no, no. He He was had to go back to Austin.
He went back home. Then he had to This was after Dude, I just
went through our text last night cuz we actually he met Kimmy
like a couple weeks before me. And so our relationship because
I was also previously married is like super convoluted. So, we
got in a huge fight and to punish me, he like had a very like
public uh driving Kimmy and like posted on his story and like
sent it to me um where he like drove her from her house to Austin
to live with her and in I guess like the
>> my husband when we when we first met um like a month
after our relationship because he was >> vindictive
um and and then he got m and then he got mad at me because I
wasn't loyal. Dude, Tim has done a lot of growing. Uh, but yeah,
he he drove her from her hometown to Austin in the U-Haul and
they did not >> very well just pulled the Oh,
>> pull the net, bro. Pull the net. >> You You cut
out there. Uh, so it was Tim drove her from her hometown or his
hometown to Austin and then you cut out >> Oh, yeah. And
then uh uh they >> I think you're about to say hooked up
with her. Yeah. Okay. >> Yeah. Yeah. They they hooked up
the the first night like in the in the U-Haul is what he will
it's crazy. There's like he sent me this message that was like
I'm going to lash out. You're not going to like it. And then
he um slept with her and then like paraded it publicly.
Um this is this is a uh this is a very long and drawn out situation
and very messy. But yeah, that's that's what happened. They hooked
up in the U-Haul.
>> Uh okay. So like
everything about you hating Kimmy for like being jealous and
that that's probably all very valer
kind of set that up. I feel like I feel like I'm understanding
so many things right now. Jealousy is like the correct and also
like I it she was used to make me upset as a tool because I would
not leave my previous partner and so that it's like a a soft
spot in the way where it's like annoying
but I don't wish I was her. Does that make sense? >> Uh
yeah I I mean sure. >> Yeah. I I it was um it was annoying.
Yeah. this like our story would and he did it publicly. He would
like pin us against each other publicly um which was annoying
but
we haven't thought about it for this has been like a very dead
thing to us but yes it it uh it stung in the beginning. Yes.
>> Okay. Sorry this is like a crazy thing to just hear
about and I didn't know >> Yeah. I didn't know about this.
Sorry. It's wild to hear about this in in the moment. Do we know
about what was because wasn't there uh I don't know if I'm caught
up. Wasn't there some text or something alluded to like 8 months
ago or whatever? Kimmy like reaching out to Gooner. Wasn't that
like alluded to? >> So she she got a really bad she got
a botched nose job in like Turkey or whatever and she was very
about it >> It was not botched. She has body dysmorphia.
She has like facial dysmorphia. Her nose has literally in every
instance looked fine. She's insane. Okay. >> It's not horrible,
but in person it's it's
she's a pretty girl. Like she's not it's just not as her old
nose looked better on her face. It's just she just looks different.
Um and
whatever. I It's not a big deal. I don't think it's she should
kill herself over it obviously, but Tim reached out to her
uh eight months ago to be like, "If you need anything, let me
know, like don't kill yourself obviously because she was in ISIS's
she was in ISIS's discord saying like that she was going to literally
kill herself. >> I read those I read those DMs and he said
that people came to his chat and said something so he messaged
her.
>> Okay. I I just didn't I didn't know because of >> and
then a couple months later she messaged him saying like it's
not fair that you didn't So this goes into a whole other thing
too because >> Okay, one second. I'm just going to pause
you. I I'll be right back in like 90 seconds. Go for it. I can
hear you >> Okay. Um, so this goes into a whole other thing
where when him and I were not together, I did not want um Kiana,
the one of the roommates did not want Kimmy to move in with her
or them and didn't know how to tell her because she liked her,
but she just didn't want to like cause drama and didn't want
to live with her. So, they were like, "How do we tell Kimmy that
she can't live with us?" And then they were like, "Tim, you should
just tell her that like you still have feelings for her, so that's
like the easiest way to do it." Um, and Tim was and Tim was like,
"Okay, I'll I'll do it." And so then like five months ago or
four months ago, she texted him saying like, "It's really upsetting
that I can't move in because of this or or whatever, even though
he didn't even live there anymore." So, I don't know what she
was thinking cuz he did he lived in Illinois with me at that
point. So, I don't know.
>> Yes. Hold on. Wait, that was not said before. Hold on.
that Tim because I thought what Tim was told, okay, was you have
to go and make sure she doesn't come in here. And what I understood
that to be was, "Hey, we don't want to live with you. It's like
a weird vibe with us." Not like I have feelings for you. Like
I'm actually in love with you or something. Is that where the
love letter comes from?
>> No, no, no, no, no. So Tim actually posted of them like
workshopping the lie and then him saying that like since he like
he wasn't going to lie to her anymore. Um, and then Kiana got
really mad at Tim and then went on live like a couple like a
day or two ago saying like that his loyalty was like not there
anymore. Like like she owned him. It was like very like she was
upset that Tim wouldn't continue to lie to Kimmy because he was
in a relationship with me and was like, "Can I just tell Kimmy
that you were lying to laugh?" Which like weird like these these
girls are so weird. Um,
>> but yeah, that was like the that was what he said to
her. Yes. So, I don't know. That's not the love letter. There's
no there's no love letter. I guess Kimmy wrote everyone letters
for Christmas one year. I think that's what Tim says that he
thinks the love letter is about, but Tim did not write her one.
So, I don't know what the I don't know >> to your knowledge
I I genuinely don't know about this. to your knowledge, was Kimmy
and Tim hooking up anything more than a hookup or either one?
>> Tim actually Tim actually had a girlfriend back at home.
Um, so I think I mean I think Kimmy's a pretty girl. I'm sure
he was excited about sleeping with her. I'm sure that he liked
her. Um, but they would like they were it wasn't like a deep
relationship. No.
for I don't know not sure what I heard but at one point I felt
like there was an implication that she had like wanted to be
with him or something. >> No. No. Neither of them wanted
to be with each other. Kimmy was would talk to Tim about Paul
and
Tim would talk to Kimmy about his girlfriend and me and it was
a Tim it was like a weird situation. I've never been in a situation
like that. I don't know. kind of disgusts me. But yeah, they
were it was not at least to my knowledge. I could be wrong. He
I my husband could be completely lying to me, but through seeing
their text messages, I there's no implication that it was more
than um hooking up with each other. >> Okay. So, all right.
And then wait, Juck, is is your opinion now that like Ice knew
the whole time and is just what trying to save face? Uh, I think
he knew that they I think he knew that they I think he didn't
know that there was like feelings is probably closer to what
it >> Well, yeah, that's what I'm asking. That That's why
I asked Lav was to her knowledge was there any feelings? >> I'm
sure that there were I'm sure there were feelings. Like I like
you like they liked each other. I don't think it I don't think
like it was completely
like devoid of any emotion. They were friends. They were good
friends. >> Wait. Okay. Maybe I'm just on my like born
Christian. When I talk about feelings, I'm talking about like
romantic feelings, not just like, hey, >> they never they
never went on >> they never went on dates or anything or
like did anything like
they were they had the roommates didn't even know about it. There
was a secret. They were like each other like at night and like
going into each other's rooms. Like it wasn't >> Yeah,
every one of those roommates knew. I'm sorry. That's a complete
cap. No, they they they didn't. They didn't. And I guess it didn't
happen like extremely
often cuz Tim was back and forth at from Illinois in LA. He only
lived at that house for like
4 months out of that >> To be fair, I I lived with a lot
of roommates. I did not know
I I didn't know anybody who slept with anybody, but I don't leave
my room, so I I didn't know anything was >> Yeah. I think
everyone was pretty self focused and they all had their own relationships
and Tim was still going on dates with other people and so was
Kimmy and Kimmy was still talking about Paul and talking about
other girls with Paul and Tim was had a girlfriend back at home
so nobody like I don't think suspected anything.
>> But they were they were good friends. They were good
friends. I mean, that's why Tim checked up on her like a couple
months ago and it was not like there was no like beef uh until
Kimmy was really mean to me at Dream Hack and Tim saw it and
was like that was weird. And then um he started seeing how psycho
she was with like doing politics against me with the roommates
and was like, "Yeah, that's like not okay. Obviously, I'm going
to stick up for my wife." But until then, they were like they
were friends like and nobody had any issue with it. like I knew
that he they were they texted each other and I mean they weren't
like texting each other texting each other but like reaching
out to each other and she said congratulations on like our wedding
post and stuff like it was not
it was not weird there was no
>> okay um h interesting oh did we get this video yet has
somebody posted this video somewhere I'm still looking for this
video that apparently Ice posted of Kimmy
did we get that somewhere stream chat checking stream chat I
asked I asked Tim's Discord. I might be able to get Oh, yeah.
>> I'm going to forward it to general chat in your I forwarded
it to general chat. >> Okay. Hold on. Apparently, uh apparently
the song's catching on. Okay. >> Oh, yeah. I saw that.
>> Josh, you tonight, dude?
>> All right. You guys are too on it. >> Hold on.
Hold on. >> All right. Turn it up.
>> Josh, you excited for tonight, dude?
No, bro.
>> Low bit rate. >> How long does it play? Is it
the whole
>> I don't know.
>> 2.4. Is the bit rate bad?
>> I'm going to taste it.
Dude, is it can't do the whole song. There's no way. For eight
bucks. No. >> Is my horn order ready, Josh? >> Dude,
these people all look like they're held hostage when like this
gets referenced. Like, they don't want to laugh. They don't want
to play into it at all. They all just look like they're
>> Like, he just >> does he even know? >> Yeah,
he Oh,
man. He he went nah right away. Like he he reacted a tiny bit.
He definitely knows. He definitely knows. Uh
he literally said he didn't want to comment about it. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Probably cuz he's in his own
>> Nick White. >> Not Nick White. Uh yeah, Nick White.
This guy's girlfriend apparently. >> Not great. >> She
He's also He also cheats on her like all the time. So they're
just like, >> "Bro, what is up with all these people each
other's What is up with >> Well, they like actually cheated
on each other. Nobody was like in a relationship I don't think
with uh Tim and Kimmy. >> Yeah. I'm just talking about
it seems like everybody in the whole sphere have all like
>> Yeah, it's very >> Check this out.
Okay, I have to upload this to streamable. Here we go. We'll
catch this video as soon as it's ready to go. Apparently Ice
leaked this. >> Any leakers? I love me some leakers. Just
don't ever leak anything on me.
>> This is July 2nd this year. >> Turn it up. You
have to turn it up. >> Really quiet. >> Why the does
he have the Oh, I have this on half. Okay. >> Goes to Photoshop.
>> Okay. You're going to get this goes to
>> Okay, dude. No one's going to believe >> I have
actual leaks of your >> photoshops are obvious. >> Yeah,
but I have real leaks that you sent up to >> like what?
>> I'm not going to tell you, >> dude. That's so
weak. They're like arguing. Real leaks that you sent to me. >> And
I have actual leaks that you >> Photoshops are off. >> Actual
leaks. feel like it makes him look worse for recording private
conversations. Like that that is >> The whole thing is
so weird. The whole thing is so weird. >> If if you're
recording private conversations, you needed to have gotten out
of that relationship and like out of the state like six and a
half months ago. Like that's insane to record private conversations.
>> And he's logging it just in case she does. Like why
are you with someone that you that you don't like that you don't
trust to not
>> publicly humiliate you? Like it's so weird. insane.
>> You've said stuff too. >> Like what? >> I'm
not going to tell you. >> That's like such a tight crop,
too, that I feel like I feel like something gets said right after
this that makes him look bad or something. Like 18 seconds, that's
the whole thing. And then you pause it. I don't think so. I think
you cut that off to to send to people. I wonder what comes after.
>> Well, I just I wonder what comes after >> Hell
yeah. >> There's tape. >> No, I don't think so. >> Can't
be. It can't be. >> This is a one party consent tape. He's
doing nothing wrong. Yeah, in Iceland you can [__]
14y olds. That doesn't mean it's okay. It doesn't mean I think
it's morally good to [__] 14y olds. >> Oh my
god.
Content brain now. >> I don't actually remember. I actually
I think it's Hold on. We'll see. >> I don't remember you
being this contentrained the last time we talked. >> It's
15. It's 15. I didn't even know it actually. Okay. I didn't even
know it actually. I just made it up. I knew it was low. >> Yeah.
I would never go to Iceland. >> Sounds like It sounds like
JTO's bin. That sounds
>> Really interesting. >> They use way too many >> still
broke the law. It sounds like he's been and still broke the law.
>> That's funny though. Wait, if it's not 14 of I get it,
but no.
>> Uh 18 and above. Okay, that's >> for you. Aren't
you like 30? It should be 25 and above for you, buddy.
>> I Okay. Yeah, I'm saying that you would
>> It would be like a morally evil thing to do. Okay.
Yeah, it's still I think it's still morally evil at 18 and 30.
It's re It's >> Listen, I'm in a monogous relationship,
so don't have to worry about it. Okay, we're good. >> Oh,
I love that for you.
>> Okay. All right. We're uh continuing here with these
logs, I guess. I don't know what this I don't know why he posted
this video. It's [__] odd.
All right. I'm not showing these to on her. Oh, yeah. We read
this. I bet there's a text somewhere where she claims she made
you. Yes, there are plenty. He says back because he's 100% going
back if she changes Lauo. No, I'm not.
There's eight caps on this. Okay.
Not good. Oh, Andy Milaninois jumps in. That was the last draw.
I have faith. He really this time. Less than 1%.
>> 1% chance. I think so. I I think so, too. But he shouldn't
have went back the other eight times as well. True. This is worse
than all the other times. It will keep getting worse if he keeps
getting back with her. And he says, "I know." Wade 225 says,
"Him saying he wants to teach her a lesson basically means he
will come crawling back in two weeks." Real. Someone reacts.
Nope, I won't. But I spent eight years with this terrible human,
so I still wish her the best of luck and at least try to learn
so she can maybe live a happy life one day. That's such cope.
That is such insane cope. Holy [__] >> Yeah,
this is so weird. That's such a weird dynamic to me because I
don't I don't go nearly as hard. and say like half of these things
like I'm going to kill this person, but I I do not wish a lot
of people well. I wish a lot of people hell. I hope a lot of
people get cancer.
Like straight up. I I don't >> It's not good to hold on
to. >> I don't I don't hold on to it. I forget these human
beings exist. Like that's just what I do. I'm like, "Oh, you
should get AIDS." And then I just forget you exist.
>> Empathy is the way to lead.
>> Oh, this is soy. Get me out of here, JTO. Just read
another log, bro. completely get me out of here.
I I find it weird that I didn't get this video when I went through
his logs today. I have like all these logs that I >> You
deleted You deleted a lot. >> This one isn't deleted. I
see it there. >> I see it there. I just It's not in my
like search or something for some reason. I don't know how I
missed this. Sorry. I'm just like This is for me. Uh my Don't
worry about it, guys. One second. Yeah, I see it here. I don't
know. Hold on. Let's go back up. Did I miss like a whole bunch
from this page or something? 230 is where this is from. I might
have missed I might have missed a lot of logs here, >> man.
This is my dog streamer, huh? >> This is my This is my
This is my base while you're >> while you're looking and
checking. This is my most base check take is that I think Kimmy
deserved
to cheat. And I think that Kimmy should mistreat someone who
wasted 10 years of her fertility.
I think like
doing that to doing that to doing that to a woman, not even marrying
her, spending 10 years with her, wasting her time in fertility
and she's 30 years old, um is like one of the most evil things
you can do genuinely. And I think it leaked that like she even
had an abortion. And I think that is like so gross. I like I
not for her to get an abortion. Obviously, she has that right,
but I think that like to not like step up and then like marry
her and like I just think it's yucky. I I I think that he deserves
everything he got and I think she should have done worse.
>> Um I don't I mean I would I think that assumes a level
of like maliciousness on his end and not like him being like
a or something. I I still think that's I you need to have enough
self-awareness to realize that like a a woman has uh like a certain
time to do things and be and I think it's extremely selfish to
not give her a family if that's what she wants. >> Is what
she wanted. >> Yes. Yes. She they broke up the first time
because she was like I want kids and he like and he doesn't want
them and then he said that he did and then they've like publicly
been fighting about that for like the last 5 years.
>> Oh. Uh, yeah. I'd say that's a pretty [__]
thing to do. >> Yeah, I think it's genuinely evil.
>> Yeah, I think it's evil. >> I mean, I imagine
at least in his head he was going back and forth about it. >> maybe.
I I still just think that like if you know that about yourself
and that you're going to waste a woman's time, uh, that you should
just break things >> Well, my argument would be I I would
have it a guess he didn't know that he was definitely not going
to have kids. I would have it a guess he would be like, "Well,
I really like her and maybe and whatever." And then was probably
kicking the can down the road and he could have been more >> self-reflective.
Do you think it's Do you think it's possible that after like
a decade together, you don't know if you want to have kids with
someone?
>> I think that's
>> uh I I don't know. How old is Paul?
>> I think 32.
I I could see that because like me for instance I >> Hey
guys, you got to get the subs in. You got to get the donation.
Donate in the chat for the links. You know, subs get the hours
up. >> Every single year I get more and more >> positive.
That makes sense. But also that's like you can't just center
yourself in that cuz you can have kids for a lot longer than
a woman can. So if you're dating a woman, you should be extremely
conscious of your aging >> I don't disagree with you. What
I'm saying is on that margin of somebody that you think you like
might love and you're going like back and forth and stuff like
that. I could see him going like in moments, especially in in
spur of the moments like, "Yeah, I could really see this." And
then in other moments, nah, I really couldn't and like maybe
I could, maybe I couldn't. >> I get that, but at that point,
stop wasting each other's time. You know what I mean? Which I
get. It's easier said than done obviously if you still love each
other, but like it's just sad. Just >> H Okay, at 219 I
miss I miss some logs. I don't know what happened here, but we
have to go through these ones as well cuz they're actually important.
And I missed one of the important ones that I saw quoted and
I was like, "Wait, did I not see that?" Cuz I that's funny as
Okay, so we'll go through these real quick as well. Uh, yes,
I'm seeing So, this is right after I believe he says she'll be
with another guy within a month. She's poor and desperate to
survive. And then he cuts over here. Yes, I'm seeing all the
things from the past now that I really that I have perspective
on and who she really is or that I have perspective on who she
really is. And it makes me never want to speak to her again.
reading back without the benefit of the doubt that she's just
naive. Everything is calculated and manipulative. The very the
face she puts on for streams is very fake. She's a bad person.
I spent six hours talking with her last night with Jay and Miochi
as a third party watching and she finally would admit to admitting
stuff and lying sometimes after 6 hours. Then the moment Jay
and Mioi leave, she immediately says she never lied. Biggest
waste of time and showed she was faking responsibility to save
face for Jay and Mio. But to me, she learns nothing. This guy
says, "Uh, Kimmy's way Kimmy's way smarter than you think. She
played you like a fiddle, Mr. 124 IQ." This guy responds, "True.
I'm sure." Now, I'm sure now she will go nuclear and she will
bring up old stuff and people. She knows how to trigger Paul.
She has nothing to lose now.
Uh, so that guy says that. Paul responds, "She would never make
herself look like a horde of the public. Lol. She cares way too
much about her image." Okay. And then this is what made him basically
when they were like, "Oh, she's going to trigger him. She's going
to nuke him. She will probably try to photoshop fake images and
make up stuff though. >> That seems like that seems like
a very preemptive like >> Yeah. Mhm.
>> I'm sure he is a piece of [__] doer.
>> Hold on now. >> I mean I would argue we have we
have >> I mean I don't think you should ever ever say you're
going to kill your partner. I don't think that should like >> you're
chimping out
>> and punch a windshield. >> Yeah. Especially while
you're breaking.
>> bro. He's got he's got deceptive punching power to [__]
break a windshield like that. Okay, >> I know, bro. I was
like, "Hey, yo, wait, hold up."
>> No, windshields are really easy to break. Windshields
are super easy to break. It's just like this >> How do
you know? >> Because I broke one when it was cold by putting
my feet up on it one time and just like pushing a little bit.
Like it's they're very easy. If it's cold, it's like the easiest
thing ever. >> Fact check that. Somebody fact check >> Okay,
hold on. Uh, now I want to play this in context of him saying
that she might photoshop or fake stuff because he says this video
is her talking about faking things.
>> Oh, hold on. >> Got a dono. Got a dono. >> What's
that? Space Ghost with a gifted sub. Thank you very much. Okay,
let me turn up here.
>> Okay, you're going to get base goes to
>> Okay, no one's going to. >> So, she says maybe.
>> Believe that.
>> And I have actual leaks of that. Photoshops are obvious.
>> Yeah, but I have real leaks that you said, too. >> Like
what? >> Okay, so she's saying >> just relaxing just
relaxing together talking about ruining each other. >> That's
actually so >> to be fair, he had come out and leaked a
whole bunch of about her like maliciously just to with her after
the cob rubs thing, right? This is July 2nd is when this comes
out. >> So like in her defense, he had just leaked a bunch
of super like reputationally harmful [__] I think
he talked about her rhinoplasties [__] her up. He
talked about a bunch of [__]
>> So I I think in her defense a little bit. Yeah. In her
defense a little bit when when she's like probably trying to
say like don't do that again or I'll leak on you like you. I
sort of get it a little bit how that
>> if your partner goes nuclear about you and wants to
completely ruin your image, of course you would start stockpiling
things against him. Yeah. >> What do you got on me? >> Oh,
you don't even want to know. >> I'll drop it like it's
hot, baby. Come on. Strike while the iron's hot. >> It's
already My drama is already fading fast. Come on. >> I
know. We need to stay. >> Was the whole like uh was the
whole trying to turn Lav and Kimmy against each other not already
like a pretty I didn't know anything about that. That was pretty
crazy.
>> I don't know about it either, man. >> So annoying.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Don't hate the
>> Oh, you're so gross.
Did Ice talk about her nose job in the capacity of like it like
it hurt her or did he talk totally psychotic because some drunk
dude fell over top of her and he was talking about how it was
like how he couldn't trust her at all and yeah he went totally
the cobbrs thing was him just going psychic >> one of her
friends thought she got her [__] up nose like it's
just a thing >> JC doesn't think it's that bad
>> I think I think that's like super super super super
super super super bad to do. Like really really bad to do >> to
your to your girlfriend. That is
>> any any friend like that's that's crazy because Yeah.
I don't I don't know what I got to know about him. I'm going
to be right back. >> That's wild. Yeah, sure. So this flip
guy asked Ice, "Why did you record? That's weird, bro. This relationship
was so over." That's very true. Uh she was saying she was going
to fake. Apparently Paul started recording. Uh there's not Oh,
sorry. But I told her to go ahead and leak my I don't care. There's
not much to leak that people don't know, dude. I I'm trying not
to do the lazy analysis and just compare this guy to somebody
else who's done these exact same things, but Jesus. Okay. Uh,
that's the only reason un the only reasonable thing to do now
is leak the nudes. That's illegal and evil. Oh, Paul's got a
Paul's got some morals. Let's go. I don't think she'll leak anything,
be it fake or real, but the fact that she's using that as a power
move shows more of her character. You both should just go your
separate ways and never interact again. You also shouldn't leak
anything or shame her publicly. Just fully let just let her go
fully. Hey, actually good advice. Don't leak or shame her publicly.
Just let her go, man. Uh I don't plan to shame her publicly.
I'm just venting on some [__] some of the [__]
I've had to deal with. Okay, but you've talked about her laboplasty.
You've talked about her rhinoplasty. Like I feel like you've
already done this. You can't be like, "Oh, well, I'm just venting
on some of the up." I feel like you've totally vented on her
somewhat private [__] already. I don't know. Maybe
the I know the nose thing was not as big of a a secret. Like
everybody f clowned on her nose, right? Like that must have been
public to everybody cuz that's like every time she goes on stream,
people start spamming TTS about her nose. >> What possess
crazy to me? >> I don't know. >> How is that not
like perma bananable inside of his his chat? She was over her
nose. No.
>> How is that not a perma? >> It's hard when you're
a streamer to not like if you feed If you feed into that by like
acknowledging that it's real and true, people will just find
other ways to harass you. So, you have to kind of do nothing.
>> I don't know. I I maybe this is uh one of many reasons
why I don't have many
>> Maybe this is one used to let us say whatever we wanted.
Kimmy changed him, man. Kimmy Kimmy ruined Ice. Ice used to let
us go wild and now Kimmy just ruined him. He banned from his
DTS rally. Can you believe that? Kimmy ruined this guy is what
people would start saying,
>> Yeah, for sure. Yeah, people people would start saying
that. I don't >> This is a guy who does not want to look
like a
at which is why I said what I said. Um and so he will not do
anything to even even to protect his like life partner. He won't
for cuz he doesn't want to look like a S. >> I can understand
him like maybe not wanting to censor people or ban people. I
can understand him wanting to let that go because he doesn't
want to let it know let people know it bothers him but to like
also play into it and start going hard on her too. That's behavior.
Like trying to avoid being a s like that you're going to lean.
>> Yeah. But he doesn't he doesn't Yeah. He just doesn't
realize that because he's like it's like he doesn't realize that
it's that's not the right move.
>> Yeah. Huh. He just right off rip. I'd be >> Yeah.
Can you Yeah. Can you imagine if we said that and I was like
I don't care. I love her. Also, were you guys kicked from the
uh were you guys kicked from the scavenger hunt? >> Uh,
he said well, we quit, but he said if we did win that he wouldn't
give us the money, so we were like, "Okay." >> Okay. All
right. Pretty much.
>> Yeah. Portoella got it just right here to the end. >> I'll
be in ninth place still. >> Yeah. If we if we go scan,
we'll be in ninth place. >> Are you guys still in Austin?
You might as well finish. I don't know why you guys wouldn't
finish. Finish right now. >> We're eating Terry Blacks
right now. We're having a lot of hotel. terrible.
>> you guys could totally you could totally win and make
him not pay you and you could make him look >> That would
be that would be the most premium [__] And if you
won, he would have to pull your stream up.
Oh my god, he pulls up the stream of you guys like winning and
then you guys just >> No, there's no honestly. We don't
we don't hate him so much that we want his like that we want
to torture him. It was like a >> Yeah. It was just a gotcha
back. >> Yeah, it was a gotcha back moment. We're not like
trying to kill him. >> Yeah, but that's not trying to kill
him. That's just making him Listen, you don't want to pay me.
>> I just be real. You know, you guys know you can't beat
Tazo anyway.
>> Guy's a machine.
>> Can't be defeated.
>> All right, now I'm going and scanning >> Tazo
looks like the iRoot guy, doesn't >> Does he? >> No,
like the robot.
>> Hold that up on screen. He like He's actually like identical
to that thing. What? No, he's not. Tazo live streamer. Hold on.
>> He absolutely is. >> No, he's not. It's not even
close. >> You're lying. >> You're You're full of
it. This is him right here. >> No, that's his most normal
photo with him smiling. You need like to see him on live stream
with in his resting state.
>> No, he looks normal. Shut up. >> He doesn't I'm
not saying he's I'm not saying he doesn't look normal. I'm just
saying it's semblant. >> Semblant. Okay, dude. Uh >> it
absolutely is in your coping. I robot
>> In fact, in fact, I asked him if he's gotten that before
and he said yes. So, >> his programming prevents him from
lying. Okay. What do you want from him? >> Do I I don't
even have the >> acts the same mannerisms. Tazo is awesome.
I hope he does win. >> Okay. All right. Well, this is the
Zim, but this is a normal picture apparently. I don't I don't
see it. I don't see it. I'm back to reading logs. Okay. Some
Spectre guy ass ice. She said she was still in love with you.
Is she trying to manipulate you?
She's not in love with me, Lauo. She don't know what love is.
That's the log I didn't I didn't see before. Oh boy. It's honestly
starting to sound like Kim is the one who had feelings for Goon
and not the other way around. That's where we're back to this
album right here. >> No, that's not true either. That's
not true either. >> It was a mutual Okay. >> There
was no like pining or anything. She It wasn't like that. >> Yeah,
we flirted. We had fun. that legacy on it. She's not that deep.
>> She was thinking of Paul the whole time.
>> She She literally was She literally was. >> You
going to try to convince me? You guys are actively trying to
convince me that there was no love there when she you like a
half like with like 3 kg of water burger across the across the
bed from you. Yeah. This is the room. This is literally Gunnar's
room. >> This is what it looked like. >> There it
is. There it is, bro. There it is. No, >> no. I This is
what this This is what I think probably happened is that Tim
is a sweet talker. I don't know if you've seen his Eate content
on Twitch. That's like what he's known for is being a sweet talker,
saying he wants to get everyone pregnant and marry them and various
things over like years and years and years. And I think she just
believed >> Yeah, she probably enjoyed the attention and
you know, we did our thing. >> That's that. >> Also,
that's not a mattress on me. That's not That's >> also
Tim is very handsome and he and he very well. Like I don't think
that you need to love someone to
>> Yeah, it doesn't hurt to taste test once in a while.
>> You're so gross. >> You know, he tries to do his
brand on stream and then he's like, "By the way, just so you
know, >> you're [__] over the nose. You're
I'm only a phone call away. I'm only a phone call away." All
right. Doesn't doesn't push it for Doesn't do anything. He's
just a kind friend. That ice kind of you, didn't he?
>> Wait. I just kind of it been 3 years. At that point,
it had been 3 years since >> He's just a sensitive guy.
He's just a kind, sensitive guy and he doesn't want to admit
it. >> Just doing a nice thing for >> Wait, are you
Are you talking about him? >> Yeah, Tim is a kind, sensitive
guy. >> I'm not exactly. >> No, he's not evil. >> He
only He only started hating Kimmy when Kimmy started being really
mean to me out of nowhere. >> You're saying the misogynist
thing is like a whole It's like a >> I can handle her talking
about me behind my back, but you're not going to do that to my
wife. There's no way. >> Yeah, she was like weirdly catty
and like possessive of Tim when like we were married. It was
like extremely strange. >> Question coming in from chat.
Uh, is there at least a sleeping bag under there or something?
Or is it just like two blankets?
>> It's like a blanket and a hoodie. By the
>> Ben Ruben donated $3 the room of the guy she blankets
to worry about is what he said. Say that again. I had a donut
coming in. Say that again. >> Two blankets, two pillows.
>> Two blankets, two pillows. Yikes.
Yikes. Sorry. Uh, we had a dono coming in. TTS, man. >> I
just watched a lot of Zirka pickup videos and I know how to do
it. >> Stop. Stop. >> Like I learned everything I
learned from John Zirka. >> John Zirka. Date IQ. Guys,
Google Date
>> That's when he was trying to get me to fly out too,
like
actively every day. And I was like, "No, dude. Like you have
not you have nothing. I'm not going to I'm not going to fly out
to you."
And it took us how a year and a half to meet in person.
>> On a win. You were in town. >> Yeah, that's true.
>> Wow. That's some crazy [__] >> Oh,
ain't that magical. That's magical. >> It really I It really
was. The second >> everything happened exactly how it was
>> The second we saw each other, it felt >> Yeah,
it was over. >> Obviously, I You guys know my situation.
Obviously, it was un ideal. I don't think you planned things
like that.
>> No, I'm full. >> You're full. >> All right,
I'm back to logs here. Uh, I'm not showing these to [__]
on her or be a bad We read all this. You We read Andy Milanis.
Where the [__] were we? Oh, we have probably were
just about at the end when we cut over. Okay.
>> That Ice got with her back with her eight times and
he thinks it's cope. I think. What was it? >> Wait, I thought
it was the opposite. I thought he said that it
>> uh that was the final strive. Oh, no. He did say the
opposite. I have faith that this won't this he really won't this
time. Less than 1% chance. Less than 1%
is completely naked right now sitting on the
10 gifties. Let's go. Let's go. All right, that's another hour
on the stream. Thank you very much. Marty Epstein. Sorry, Tim's
naked. That's fantastic. This guy just sent me
>> completely butt naked
barbecue.
>> Let's go. Yeah, that's what vacations are like. Thank
you very much, Marty Epstein. Appreciate it, buddy. Appreciate
you.
All right, we hear I get >> says, "Dude, shut the up. She
did the same to me when you broke up and I called her out on
her BS. She isn't learning and I will continue to do this BS."
So, she did the same to me when you broken up. I don't even know
who this mentalist guy is. I don't know why he's saying this.
Then she will die alone or miserable in a failed marriage is
how Ice ends his rant from last night. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Okay, that's it. That's it for Ice's logs. That's
it for his crash out. That's it. That's all. >> We're caught
all the way up, guys. Putting a cap on it. >> Odds they
get back together.
>> They're If that's crazy if they do. >> I think
80% chance they get back together. Uh within a year. >> I
was going to say, yeah, >> within a year. I I think there's
a >> he has to quit streaming then. >> He just has
to keep it a secret,
>> He's uh >> He has to keep it a secret.
>> Oh, he could he could keep it a secret. I think he'd
lose their viewers.
>> Yeah, he could. Yeah, he could actually just say like
I love her and you know it is what it is. >> Even when
she cheated, she just didn't tell the truth. >> Yeah, it
wasn't that big of a deal. Hannah, I think hit the nail on the
head. It like what? It actually wasn't that big of a deal. >> What
did she actually do? I'm still confused. What lie did she tell?
>> She narrative spun that like I guess that they hadn't
really had and that Tim had just like really tried to have sex
with her and she rejected him many times.
Um, and that it was like not serious. Uh, which was like not
>> it was >> Where are you getting that from though?
>> Uh, Hannah uh, every single friend deathly ill said
that >> because Hannah's best friend definitely said, just
to be clear, Hannah definitely said that he knew 100%. >> Uh,
no, but I So you're So this is where it's getting convoluted
is that Hannah I don't think knows the full truth either. I think
that Kimmy gave everyone that she knew a narrative to for
Like her her best friend, Deathly ill, like said the same thing
that she rejected him multiple times. And like she's she's obviously
like she's built a narrative that
like I don't know what nobody knows. Nobody knows what anyone
knows because Kim like Kimmy wasn't honest with anyone. I when
I asked her, >> somebody should have some logs or something
and the only people who have spoken on this are so when she asked
you or sorry when you asked her, she said, "Yeah, Paul knows
like the broadstrokes." So I need to know. Okay. >> He
needs to know.
>> No, I was just like
>> there's a joke there. I'm not going to make it. Okay.
Needs to know the broader like anybody who's got a girth. But
I >> Anyway, uh >> Okay. Go Sam Pepper. And Pepper
kept teasing in Tim's logs like on chat like, "Oh, the love letters
you wrote." And then
there were like logs between Tim and Kimmy and was like, "Why
are you baiting me?" Like, "Why? What?" Like, "Why did you tell
Sand Pepper and those logs are already public?" >> Sure.
So, I've not seen any indication that Paul didn't know yet and
that she was telling basically that she told Paul something different.
>> Just Paul saying that he didn't know. Yeah. Just say
just just Paul saying that he didn't know the extent of it is
is the only proof. >> I guess >> I think I think
he heard some I think she probably said some that wasn't like
incredibly clear but like if we if we read it and we didn't want
to think about it. Okay. Sorry. We we wanted to think about it.
I think he doesn't want to think that she some other guys. So
when he reads like oh well you know we were kind of together
>> I think he reads that as something. That's what I'm
guessing. It would have
>> it would have been normal and fine if like if Tim and
Ice Poseidon never rubbed shoulders. The the part about it that
was weird is that like Tim was like >> it was in like an
intimate like rat race event where it was like less than 10 people
involved
>> and there and he was like yeah he was doing events with
him and getting opportunities from Ice Beside it and Kimmy had
not told him the full truth but was feeding telling well she
was telling Tim that like she was h like hamming it up and saying
it was okay and Paul didn't care but then Paul was saying that
Kimmy was was saying that she like didn't want him to be in events
and Paul was like, "Oh, but I like him. He's funny." So, she
he like she put her in like she put him in like a very
>> Yeah, it was brutal.
>> Yeah, kind of. But that's only Paul saying that too.
And I don't know what the actual case is there. Like I don't
know if you guys go. I >> like it could easily be that
after you and her got into those DMs where she talked about like
what is Paul gonna leak, right? or sorry you talked about what
is Paul going to leak this is July this is a month and a half
ago okay it's very possible that she went oh Paul I don't want
them at uh I don't want them at scavenger hunt and to me I'm
like okay different she has like some reason to say I think these
people are doing weird [__] >> I don't know
who's lying cuz Kimmy sent me like a big long message that was
like yeah Paul doesn't Paul doesn't like him and I've been trying
to go to bat for him and I was like okay um and then Paul's saying
that it was the exact opposite I have no idea who's lying like
I don't Obviously, Ice Poseidon is a very egotistical man. I
don't think that he would admit that he
I don't know. It's actually more to do what he's doing. I think
if he was like, "Yeah, meant so little to her that like I and
we're together that like I didn't care if Tim was around." Like
that that was that would be the strong
choice. I don't know why he didn't do that. If it is true that
he knew. >> I don't know. >> Well, he's got to save
face for his audience. Like >> Yeah, but that's the way
to save face with your audience to be like, "Yeah, I didn't care
that he was around." Thank you. I don't care. I had him around
because it's content and because it's funny for you guys. You're
welcome. >> I don't know why he went the other way. >> No,
no, no. All of his chat is going to if basically if he says that
he knew that Gunnar his girlfriend, all of his chat's going to
call him a regardless of whether or not he like he's just a no
matter what, right? >> But he Yes. But he can I mean no
matter what. Yeah. But he can control that narrative and save
his relationship by being like I don't care. Adults have sex
with each other. Like I we are together now and we love each
other. Like that's >> Yeah, but he doesn't I haven't seen
any indication he can stand against the tide on that. Yeah, I
have I haven't seen anything to audience enough to do that to
his audience. That's like >> Yeah. If you don't know how
to stand up to your audience, you're a slave. >> Yeah,
that's like stupid. >> Yeah, I think he is. I think he
is a slave to his audience. >> Yeah, I do. >> That's
That's sad. I So maybe he's Maybe he's lying. I >> I don't
know. He did say that Kimmy said that she forgot to tell him
>> in logs like a couple days ago. Uh,
>> so I don't It sounds like something she would say because
she's so I I don't I don't know. I forg. >> Okay. Well,
I'm just I'm trying to keep everything straight like what I know,
what I've read, what I've seen evidence of. So, when I hear something
that like, oh, I'm like, no, I I don't think that's proven. I
just need to ask.
>> The only They have posted no evidence towards each other,
it's really interesting. I I I'm I think they're scared to like
open the floodgates. The only pictures of like logs that have
been released or leaked have been like Tim's and hers and Kiana's
and like nobody nobody else is posting anything. >> They're
not being transparent at all. >> No, it's like very strange.
They're being very weird. >> Also, were they were they
so they they weren't dating at the time, right? like they were
>> no they weren't dating but Tim has told me that she
would they would give each other relationship advice like so
I I think that she she wanted to get back with Paul like she
still loved Paul >> yeah she was going on dates with other
guys too like it wasn't like >> but she was yeah she was
obvious she was saying that she missed Paul
>> yeah so I don't know I don't know if they were talking
or not at that point
I don't know I don't I honestly I get how this is that big of
a deal. I like what I'm saying
to take him down, but yeah, I think that it was good enough to
like make him to humble him, but I didn't realize it was going
to be like this crazy. I I don't think it's that big of a deal
either. I think people >> Yes, you did. Oh my god. Do not
cope on >> No, no, no. I No, no, no. I No, I'm not coping
on this. I obviously knew that it was going to affect him. I
didn't realize that this was going to be like
I didn't like there's people are trying to like cancel people
like this is like obviously this is not cancelable. Like they're
they're now they're talking about like releasing logs of each
other. Like I did not know that it was going to be like that.
I thought it was just going to be like yeah like my my husband's
the man and your girlfriend. >> I Okay. All right. I don't
want to argue but I feel like I'm pretty confident that you had
a good idea that this is going to stir up between them. I'm pretty
confident. >> Okay. Are you not hearing me? Are you not
hearing me when I literally said >> I'm saying that? Yeah.
You knew it would cause a bunch of strife between them. You knew
he would get giga
>> and you knew that and you taunted him with it in the
>> I knew I knew he would get I knew he would
change the stream.
>> No, no. I knew that he would get giga but the way that
Kimmy related to me was that he did not care because it was so
insignificant in those logs. So obviously I knew that he would
take a bite with his audience. I did not think it was going to
cause in extreme strife in between them because she said that
they had worked it out in the logs. I literally posted.
>> I literally thought that he I literally thought I thought
that he was just going to get choked up and be and then that
was going to be it. >> Yeah, I sorry. I still don't believe
that. But we can read it. So, where does he say one drama either?
I've never tried to make anyone's life harder. I'm sorry that
you're stressed. Hold on. I just need to make sure I have this
in timewise like in the right order. You win. >> Yeah,
it looks probably good. What is >> She was saying she was
saying I didn't make it I didn't make it significant. I didn't
make it significant. Well, first she deleted the message that
that said that Paul didn't like it and then she reiterated that
he didn't care. So, it's like I don't even know. I don't I don't
know. She's not an a very eloquent communicator. It's probably
there. It's >> I have these like way out. >> She
said something like I I did not make it significant. >> This
album is stupid. Whoever put this album together is a is like
not in time-wise order at all. So, it goes from this one up to
the top. >> I was under the impression that he knew >> I
was under the impression that he knew and that also he would
um that he was going to say something about it to humiliate Kimmy
because that's what he had been doing for a month um by exposing
her
with other things. So, I didn't think that it was going to I
didn't think I don't know. I actually don't know what I thought,
but I I just wanted him to uh bleed a little bit, a lot of it.
>> So, she says, "I have never made it significant to Paul,
and I vouched for Gunnar to be invited to events and things for
that reason. He didn't want him around, but I said how he wasn't
going to tell people, and that I think he is a good person and
will remain respectful."
So, she says that, that's not saying Paul doesn't care. That's
saying Paul does care and is annoyed about it, right? Paul doesn't
want him there. That's what she's saying. >> Okay. And
then we go from there. I think we go up right up to here. And
it's like, uh, Lav, I don't want drama either. I've never tried
to make anyone's life harder. I'm sorry that you're stressed
about this and worried about being brought into it. I'm doing
everything to try to keep the peace. No one is coming after you.
And I'm telling you everything you I know. I'm sorry if it upsets
you for me to tell you that Paul didn't like this or that. It's
Paul's feelings. I don't control them. >> I don't even
know I don't even know what I don't even know what she was talking
about there. Honestly, >> uh, well, she just finished saying
that Paul was annoyed about it, right? Well, I don't Well, it's
hard because she deleted that big long message before the thoughts
thing. I
But yeah, I she had relayed
in a message to Tim as well that he did not that she did not
care, which has also been released, I believe. >> Well,
he she's saying she's saying like don't with them cuz they'll
leak about people and they don't care, right? But I don't even
know. >> Yeah. Well, yeah. So, the the energy the energy
changes when she was like he has nothing to lose. he doesn't
care about your feelings. And so I was like, I don't know what
is he going to release that's going to like affect me deeply.
I she like kind of she was all over the place. It was like hard
to parse. >> Uh I think when she says like it's Paul's
feelings when she says that Paul like didn't want him around.
I feel like she's telling you that Paul was like frustrated by
this. >> But then she said that he could leak it. So I
was like confused on how much he cared obviously. And then with
the messages between her and Tim,
she said that it he like was over it and that it was whatever.
>> And like how much do you how much do you care about
humiliating yourself if if you are going to leak it because you
have nothing to lose? I I don't know. >> Well, I if they
broke up, she could get leaked, I'm guessing. And they they clearly
were like melting down on this day, right? the the video was
she was she was saying if if we did anything though is what am
I for if I'm misremembering she was like if you do anything like
he has nothing to lose he doesn't like the way that you cuz Tim
had gone over their drama a month prior and was like yeah this
is pretty bad when they were like when he was threatening to
kill himself and stuff and Kimmy had said that yeah Paul doesn't
like that you uh did that so he could leak like she was um
she was It was um
confusing and I'm still confused. >> Wait,
I I don't understand. >> I don't I think
I I don't think it's confusing, but it's okay.
>> No, it it is it No, it it's not confusing to to me.
It's confusing. I'm like trying to
She deleted four paragraphs. So, I'm like I'm trying to relay
them to you, but obviously like I don't think that you will believe
me because you cannot see them. Are these Discord messages? They're
Discord messages. >> Yeah, they're Discord messages. So,
I'm like I'm trying to like tell you the narrative, but I'm also
not trying to look like psycho feeding you something that I can't
prove. Do you know what I
>> Okay. Yeah, that makes sense. I just like in my head.
Okay. The reason that you can't prove that to me with just your
word is cuz like in my head I knew you wanted to hurt Ice in
that moment and so this was the information you used to hurt
him, right? So, when you say like, "Oh, I didn't think you really
cared." It's like, "No, I think you probably had a good idea
he cared when you said it. That's all. Right. Like you were you
were saying it too hurt him because he was talking shagunar.
>> Yes. But it's it's a it's a matter of it's a matter
of how much he cares and what it hits. So I didn't think that
it was going to hit his partner insecurity. I thought that it
was going to hit his ego because he talks about his money so
much and he talks about how he can, you know, he can provide
and that's who he is. I I thought that oh the fact that his girlfriend
is doing these things for someone who had none of those things
is going to hurt him. I I I
wasn't thinking about whether or not he knew and if it would
blow up their relationship in a big way. I thought maybe he'd
be upset that she had done that. Yes.
>> Um I feel like those are the same thing. I don't think
you I don't think you really if you think about it now. Okay.
Maybe he didn't think about >> No, I if I think about it
now insecurity >> those obviously feed into each other
completely, right?
>> Sure. But he also he kept doing things where I felt
like he was baiting Tim like with steak chests and like with
other like I it felt like he was he knew what he was doing. I
felt like he was baiting him and then with the threat that Kimmy
had given me and then with Paul calling
uh Tim a loser I was like oh he's like going he's going to say
something before we do surely. >> I know that might not
make a lot of sense to people outside of the >> It's it's
hard because you don't know who Kimmy is. Yeah, >> but
we've been dealing with this for a while now. Like the little
social espionage
behind the scenes. >> It's like it's hard to explain, especially
because like she looks so stupid to you that you're like not
you can't it's like hard to
understand that she's like extremely manipulative and like wonky
and communicates poorly on purpose. >> Maybe. Yeah, sure.
I don't I don't even necessarily think that like what Kimy's
saying here like you could say all of that. I just don't think
that changes much in terms of like what your motivation. Sorry,
it's just the motivation when you said it to Paul. >> No,
I'm you you seem to think that you seem to think that like I'm
saying no, I didn't want to hurt him. And that's not what I'm
saying at all. >> No, I'm saying that [__]
>> I'm saying I'm saying that you you keep saying, "Oh,
I thought it would do a little bit of damage." And I think what
I'm saying is you knew it was going to
every likelihood of cutting his head off right live on stream
and you were like, "Yeah, you deserve that." If you got if that
if it hits you that bad, you deserve it. That's all I'm saying.
And I said that you thought you weren't going to hurt him that
bad. It's just to me I'm like, "No, you knew I said this to you
the other day. I said this to you the other day. I was doing
an air strike. I was not trying to like nuke the center of the
world." >> Yeah. And I'm saying you you're doing an air
strike that you knew had like a 30 or 40% chance of getting >> For
what reason would I have to lie about this? For what reason would
I have to lie about this? I do not like him. >> I don't
know. >> I' I've been very I've been very very vocal about
not liking him and thinking he's a scumbag. >> It would
it would not look great if if we're being honest. It would not
look great if you released private information like that to like
blow up a guy's relationship. >> Yeah. Do you think that
I care about my online reputation? I literally propagated the
rumor that I dog online. >> Well, I mean, you don't you
care about your online reputation? Isn't that like 80% of the
drama that you're in? You don't want
>> Wait. Yes. You Isn't the whole thing that like you think
other people
like uh lie about you or say that you lie when you don't and
then therefore you get >> No, that's No, no, no. It's annoy
It's annoying when I'm telling the truth about someone like Destiny
and people are saying, "Oh, you're lying." It's like it obviously
it's the boy who cried wolf. So like I'm so jester pilled that
when I'm actually telling the truth people are like not believing
me which is obviously like upsetting to me and so I try to fight
that. >> Exactly. Caring about your online but yes but
that's 10 that's 10% of my of my existence online with the rest
of it. I don't care if I'm the villain obviously. >> I
mean you could say that but at the end of the day you care about
your online. >> So I forgot how you guys are. >> Jesus
Christ. Uh do you have a source for that?
>> I forgot how you guys are in this community. It's like
>> I should go autistic nerds.
>> I don't even know. I got caught in this loop. I got
caught in this loop that we always get caught in where like you
zero into like one part of what I'm saying and I and it's like
impossible to prove to you how I'm feeling inside of my >> You
guys could go out and just go to a bar and talk to
>> That's enough. No, it's >> No, no, it's it's annoying,
but it's this this isn't even part of >> this makes any
sense. I mean, >> we're just doing a normal loop where
you guys are trying to like make me loop. Whatever. I >> It
doesn't Okay, I get it. I get it. I'm evil. I did it all. I did
it all on purpose. It would not make a difference either way.
Honestly, it would not evil. >> I don't I don't think you're
evil. >> Okay. Holy Holy What's going on? Okay. Yeah. I
Let's >> Could you stand on it? >> Yeah. For the
for the sake of the story. for the sake of the story. Yes, I'm
evil and I wanted to I wanted to kill both of them and and uh
and yes, I I don't even think it matters that much to the story
>> Sure. I as far as I as far as I see it, the primary
thing that matters is whether or not you acknowledge that Kimmy
knew that or Kimmy had told Ice the full extent of the situation.
That's it. I I have no idea what they all I know is that Kimmy's
a huge [__] and I didn't care about her as collateral
and I wanted to hurt Ice Beside him. That was like the everything
in my brain >> and scene. >> Yeah. That like that
was not it was not even like it was like semiculated where when
he started messing with Tim I was >> oh like I'm going
to destroy him. >> Maybe that's a better way. Maybe that's
a better way. I I don't even think you thought you were going
to destroy him. I thought I think your thought process was this
is the most damaging thing I can say right now. you. Yes, >> that's
what I think your thought process >> So, but then you keep
saying like, "Oh, I thought it would do this much." No, no, no,
no. This is the most harmful thing I could say to you right now.
>> How could I do you think that I sat Do you think that
I sat there and I planned out and then in my brain I I saw the
butterfly effect of everything that would happen? But that's
what you've
>> That's what 60 HP is. I had no idea. Yes. I thought
that I would I I bit him. I didn't think that I hit an artery.
>> Autism wins again. This is This is the same thing. Autism
wins again. We're on the same page now. Yes.
>> Yes. We I hate I hate these loops. I hate them. And
I hate that I do them with you. It is not even important to >> We're
on the same page now. We're on the same page, though. Awesome.
>> Boom. There it is. Hey, sometimes you got to cook. Sometimes
there's not like that much content here. It's not that much meat
on the bone. So, we got to cook up some paid by the hour. We
know what you're doing, man. Nobody cares. >> That's true.
>> We know the game. >> I'm getting my air time and
I don't even have to send you pictures of my feet. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Okay.
Is there anything? You guys should go back. You guys should win.
You should try to win. We'd help. You guys are gonna go back
and try to win. We would help. >> Have you gone through
all of the logs? >> Have we gone through Oh, wait. Did
I not? There's like a Kimmy logs. There's a set of >> Yeah,
there's no way that you went through all of the logs. >> We
went through all the ice logs from today. Yeah, we did.
>> Lab set this whole thing up to get invited back on this
stream. That's >> She was thinking ahead. >> I didn't
know. Okay, hold on. Did you? Yeah, the villain that nobody thought
that they needed.
I didn't even realize that Ice was a bigger scumbag than I thought.
I learned about the crypto rug pulling later in the Darius uh
Zeno stuff later. I just thought that he was super mean to my
husband and other people and I was like I saw him pay Shuy to
like um to eat a to put in >> Hold on. Hold on. I don't
think it's like that bad cuz he he's very transparent about what
you're opting into. Like nobody's ever looked at Ice Besides
content before they go on like a collab with him.
>> This is the same thing with Destiny literally as like
these Can you Do you genuinely think that someone like Shuy can
consent? Like >> Yeah. Like he shouldn't be allowed to
like sign waiverss or do anything. >> Yeah. These people
are like desperate and like and wanting to like be big streamers
and they'll do anything. Like >> Do you think the perk
should be even allowed to roam the streets? Like these are the
people we're talking about here. I made a choice going into these
events and I did well in every single one of them that I performed
in. And >> that's why you you were in a different position
than everyone. >> He always tried to give it back to me
because I wouldn't like >> Yes. He like he wanted Yes.
He wanted to make you kneel and you wouldn't. So he like picked
on you in like a very weird >> Yeah. He he specifically
targeted me with weird [__] and I I know what he
was >> Yeah. He's >> He didn't know what I was doing.
>> He's just like,
>> "Wait, you actually think he was trying to like with
you? Like actually [__] with you? You don't think
he was verifiable guys were talking? >> I have verifiable
proof of him like dropping chests for like $500, me driving to
them and he goes, "Oh, Gunnar's moving fast. Go's in a car."
And it deactivates the chest right when I get >> Yeah.
He's like trying to make him look stupid like
>> that. Um >> or with the Hunger Games stuff. >> Yeah,
there's a bunch of other examples like he he's constantly tried
to little bro me because I wouldn't kneel to him. like the >> called
you a loser. Said that you were like a gay little complainer
when you were just like, "Dude, the >> I was critiquing.
>> These hints are stupid." >> Yeah. I was telling
him like, "Hey, nine days straight doing a scavenger hunt. Probably
not very fun." Or how many days in be like four? >> Yeah.
But you were like, "This can't go two weeks." Like these hints
like it can't take two days to do one. >> I broke his game.
Like I've tried the first two days and by day five I'm still
in the top 10 with points. I'm literally still top 10 if I just
go scan the things. Like I have 10,400 points. I could still
make my name show up on his screen right now if I go scan them.
Like his game is broken. It's I tried to tell him that. I tried
to communicate that, but then I got called a complainer because
the game is gay. >> Yeah. And then he and then he was like
he was just trying to ego and little bro him which I obviously
didn't like. And >> and I obviously did overreact.
>> Wait, you know that he thinks he worked hard on it,
right? That he thinks he put like all of his time into it. You
You know that would piss him off if you're going to complain
about how it is. >> Yeah, but you need to humble yourself.
like I don't care if you built the World Trade Center. >> The
problem is that Tim does not respond to authority well and obviously
neither do I. And uh like Ice putting himself positioning himself
above us ego wise and not having like a conversation. I think
he we believed that we were not the sort of people that um like
want to do a humiliation ritual. Like that's not why we did it.
But he wanted everyone to do his content to be doing humiliation
rituals. So, it was like very annoying when he'd talk to us like
we were below him because he had like a platform. >> Day
four, we literally
>> Hold on. You guys are below him totem pole of like CX,
right? Like, no, no offense. I don't think you're below. >> No,
no, no, no, it's not. It's not that. It's not that. Obviously,
he's the one putting on the event and we were all so humble and
gracious talking to him. Like, we understand that this is hard.
>> yeah, we were just giving critiques and then he switched
some of this. like he literally integrated some of the feedback
that we had when we had a call with him like day three or four
>> and we were like, "Hey, this gay um change this, do
more of this. The chests are fun. Let your little content monkeys
do their thing." >> But then he just wouldn't lay off like
>> and then he tried to make you a content monkey the day
after. >> Yeah. Then he tried to like drop >> because
he knew because you we humiliated him by like cuz even Sam Pepper
was like no what Lav is saying has legs and people were like
she's right she's right she's right. So then he like tried he
was even like he was trying to get Tim to go to uh chess and
>> yeah do again this is not a big deal either like we're
not yeah we're not we're not saying like oh my god he's sabotaging
us you know me I would have released anything I had on him at
like a slight inconvenience. >> Yeah like you stub your
toe when you wake up that morning it's over [__]
>> I'm obviously very quick trigger like I'm not saying
that he did something egregious. I'm just saying like, yeah,
obviously if you piss me off and I have information about you
and you're like trying to ego me like, yeah, may maybe that's
that maybe that makes me a bad person. I think it makes me a
fun person. But >> yeah, and he kept dropping steak chests
on me and I I kept baiting him. I got him to drop two steak chests
on me just by trolling. And then I had my friends pick him up
like I don't need them. >> And then he and then even and
he knew that like me and Tim got in a huge fight this this past
couple weeks because of his gambling stuff. And he kept like
trying to and he was like, you know, she Oh, the wife isn't around.
Yeah. And and we I like we did a whole stream literally that
day where we were like I was like almost in tears being like,
"You have a problem. Like we can't do this." Like he knew how
serious it was. It wasn't like a >> You know, >> but
nothing's nothing's off limits except for his >> Hey, that's
a point I made last night. Yes, the steak chest thing is up.
like knowing that that's a trigger and that he's like that is
with somebody past the point of just banter, right? >> Yeah.
Like that's hitting on a relationship pain point. So Ice was
uh didn't like that Goonar and Lav were I guess giving him feedback
and he kept dropping stake chests on Goon's car around Goon,
right? Goonar and Lav just had a big fight over Goonar gambling
on stage, right? He's kind of like Darius in that way a little
bit. Okay, he should know better, but he doesn't for some reason.
Okay. So, Ice was doing that to with him even knowing that they
were doing the event together and that they just had a massive
fight about it, which he could say is content, but then
>> you don't get respect back, right? >> No, he knew
that. You don't get the respect back in my opinion. >> Was
Was there any chance that he did it without thinking? >> No.
Just said that. He said, "The wife's not around right now. Go
grab it." >> Yeah. He literally he literally actively said
like >> Yeah, he he knew that we were fighting about it.
Yes, he knew. And Kimmy knew. Kimmy said it in like a whole thing
uh yesterday where she was like, "And they and they just fought
and he was gambling to the like she obviously knew so he knew."
Like it was it's very public that we that Tim has a gambling
addiction and we're working through it. >> And here's the
thing, like before we released all this, nobody else in his community
or his orbit will give him genuine feedback. >> That's
true. Everyone's so scared of >> I loved the events that
I parttook in. I I enjoyed them tremendously. probably some of
the most fun I've had on stream. But nobody was willing to tell
him, "Hey, this sucks. Fix this. Fix that." And then you're going
to have more content. You're welcome. >> Everyone else
is just so scared to like raise their voice in front of their
god and their because of the way that he
like they're scared because he's going to destroy them. They're
scared cuz he like literally if he was in my psychotic was like
these people. Is there any doubt in your mind that if he was
in my position, he would have done anything
>> He would have been more calculated about it. I think
he would have been more calculated about it.
>> Just wait till the action man stuff comes out. >> I
I'll keep that one in the back burner. >> Yeah. Are you
talking about Jamie or you are you saying Ice Jamie? Cuz you
just said ice. >> Oh, no. I'm not saying anything like
that. I'm just saying I'm just saying that there's some stuff
action in ice. >> So, you're saying that didn't happen
>> the ice didn't [__] No, I didn't
>> Okay. All right. >> Ice can't get women. Ice can't
get women. He pays for it, man. The lesson. >> When Hannah
was like all these girls, I'm like, "No, he didn't, dude." Like,
there's no way. Like, >> yeah. How does Nick White have?
I'm very confused there. >> I Well, I think that >> Nick
White is like the most depressing human being to be around.
>> He's actually vampire. I don't know. I think he just
tires them out by proximity and then they >> I think Jamie
was probably exhausted because Action Man is sort of known for
like messaging every single person. I think Jamie was just trying
to get a quick lick in which I think she probably >> Yeah.
None of these people are friends. They all use each other. They're
all scumbags and sometimes King Scumbag gets scumbag back. That's
the long and short. >> Do you JSTLK? Do you think there's
any
Do you do you think that I'm a a person who appreciates powerful
men above me with arrogance? I'm not unearned
>> Yeah, I Yeah, I'm I I am
I am happy and excited to do what I did to Ice Poseidon, too.
I two people I think deserve it. >> Okay,
that's fine. All right, hold on. We got more uh Hannah, not Hannah,
but Kimmy logs here. One second. So, last night she said, "I'm
not the victim. Paul is." And then, "I'm in love with him, too."
This was like total cope mode. I couldn't believe she was saying
this. It was like clear she just wanted to uh make him better,
make him not hurt in the moment. Uh, let's pull this next page
up. If I cared about viewer validation, say this is today. If
I cared about viewer validation, I would fight back. I wouldn't
be taking all the punches. I would speak up and I'm choosing
not to. I'm most definitely mad at Goar and laugh. I'm not mad
at Paul. I understand why he's upset and he is under a lot of
stress right now. I don't know when I should speak up and say
my side. Or if Paul wants me to stay quiet about it forever,
then I will. I haven't watched a single stream since this all
happened. There absolutely is. I can't I don't know what this
is. There absolutely is. I'm >> I haven't watched a single
stream since any of this all happened. Is the craziest lie. Just
explain this one. Kimmy will watch people's streams
offline and >> if she's mentioned in an 8hour stream, she
knows about it. >> Yes, it is so strange. She has hit people
up and asked like, "What was this interaction about?" She is
extremely insecure and she will comb through VOD after VOD looking
for any mention of her. The woman is deranged.
>> Seems like there's a there's a fair bit of those vibes
in that community. It's
>> I his community is so sick and twisted though that I
it could make any woman like actually so I don't even actually
>> knock her for that. >> Yeah. No, I I obviously
think she's deal she's been dealing with a lot for the last decade
cuz they're insane. Well, the thing the thing I don't understand
is what what is she? So, I'm most definitely mad at Goonar and
Lav.
But the problem is wouldn't
you guys being at fault make her the principal at fault because
she didn't communicate to Paul? >> She is. I'm telling
you, she is. And I'm and I'm trying to be nice and not come off
as like jealous and insecure when I say this. She is genuinely
so stupid. I don't think she understands like self-reflection.
Like I don't even think that she has the capacity to take accountability.
She's like she's like a fly cleaning herself. It's like a fly
cleaning itself. It's like not it's like when you're in a room
with her, it feels like you're in a room with a horse or a >> Wouldn't
want to sound like you hate her or anything though. >> She's
No, she's an a she's a she's a But I'm not I'm not saying this
because of the situation. I'm saying this like you I mean Mondo
said it. Mondo said the same thing and Mondo has no tie to her.
Like it is lit. It is literally like being in a room with a horse
or a cow. >> But didn't you say earlier that she you you
think that she you weaponizes
like a perception of her inability, but she
>> Yes. It's hard. It's there's no way for me to know what's
in her head. Obviously, I'm only human. I'm not I can't mind
read her. But it's She'll have moments of cunning where like
when she like But it's obviously it's it's not very like well
thought out. So, like in her big message to me yesterday, she
brought up like like Tim's mom and how Tim's mom liked her or
something. And like it it obviously is like she knows where to
put the knife, but she doesn't realize how to hide it. Does that
make sense? Like she she's
she's like she's >> Yeah. She's cunning enough to where
she like knows what is right or wrong. She's not like an automaton,
but she's like it's it's hard to explain it. It's It's hard to
explain. There's like no light in her eyes. I don't know how
to explain >> She doesn't have the spark. She's not been
in sold. >> I Yeah, that's what it it literally fel when
I went up to her and and introduced myself. It felt like I was
like feeding a horse a carrot. >> Okay, Jtock, work with
me on this because I feel like I mean Leav, you can too, but
is there I don't I genuinely don't understand that message. I'm
most definitely mad at Goonar and Lav. Is there a single universe
in the multiverse where
Gunnar and Lab did something wrong and she and Kimmy >> No,
she's just not self-aware. She's She's not smart enough to reflect.
>> Yeah, she >> she could have told Paul, let's say
hypothetically this is the world where Paul goes, "Okay, just
tell me like was there something that like but don't tell don't
give me details. Just tell me like is there anything for me to
worry about there?" And she goes, "No, like nothing for you to
worry about. We we're together, but like it's not anything."
>> If that's the conversation,
Oh, >> For lying. She lied. >> I think she's I think
she's really mad. >> We were together. >> We were
together. >> Oh, sorry, bro. I keep for I'm I'm so compelled.
I When you I hear together, I don't think we I >> Well,
but that's what I'm saying is so I think that is a like that
is a cleverly phrased way to say I see what you're >> She
told Paula,
"Did you this guy?" And she said, "No, I did not." Then she is
a liar and she does have a ton of follow. still trying to deny
it. She literally she in her messages she goes back and forth.
This is why it's hard to
like tell you what is going on cuz she's an unreliable narrator.
She said that she didn't. She's still telling her friend Deathly
Ill that she didn't. Deathly Ill said literally two days ago
that she kept rejecting him. So like she had a completely different
narrative. Like every it's it's
on stream. Uh >> no. It's in the Discord. >> Would
you know what Discord it was in? >> No, I don't. >> I
think it might have been Kimmy's
>> Oh, Kimmy got a Discord, bro. >> I I would say
in that I would say in that reality then she would still be at
fault for like,
you know, very spec tricky phrasing, right? But my my problem
is like I don't I don't see the only reality I can think of is
where in which she told Paul and she was totally honest and then
Paul
uh uh
She told Paul and Paul was she was totally honest with Paul.
She uh told Lav
like not to say anything and then for some reason Paul publicly
maybe only to save face said uh I'm really upset with Kimmy.
I'm breaking up with her. Cold her in public and all this [__]
just to save face. That's that's the only reality where I can
see that she is totally blameless. Well, I think this is I I
don't >> I think what she's talk what she's speaking to
is the fact that it's public. I said that uh she is someone who
only cares about her perception and she is she's she does politics
and within her friend groups. She doesn't want anyone. She has
said for years, I don't answer questions on on uh online. Like
she she's obviously someone who wants to come off as very controlled,
very uh stable, and doesn't want like people to think that she's
crazy or a or that she has any bad traits. And I think that she
is upset with me and Tim because we exposed something about her
to the to the community that wasn't public, not even necessarily
Paul. M >> m yeah that's what I mean that's how I would
feel too. So >> anyway sorry hold on I'm getting I'm getting
these messages from deathly ill right here uh in the discord
last night. So she might have said other things here but I don't
know >> she had said like oh Kimmy rejected him so many
times uh like something like that like those were the messages.
So I don't even know I don't she's telling some everybody close
to her has a different story.
>> She said relationships are not easy. I believe you two
can make amends when you're not exhausted and under emotional
terrorism from outsiders.
Okay.
Uh you literally just join the Discord and have zero context
for anything. Shut your mouth, dumb.
Okay. >> Yeah, this this their community is so toxic. It's
like it's >> Yeah, man. True, man. So true, man. Do you
see this person? Uh this was deleted. I don't know what that
was. I brought Carmen's bed into this room when he left. I something
about her boyfriend. I don't know. Okay. And then Never mind.
I start I started copying all these cuz I thought it was going
to be relevant and it's literally not at all. Anyway, Kimmy continuing
the Kimmy logs. So, she's talking about the love letter. By the
way, there somebody somebody's asking about the love letter.
There absolutely is one and I'm keeping it until I can e it either
100% it's either 100% over or until Paul says I can. And if he
never says I can, then I'll just hold it in and take the bunches.
Or maybe >> that's not about the love letter. >> Yeah,
that's definitely not about the right thing. >> Guys, there
is there is literally there is no love letter. Like there's no
there's no this is I don't even know where Sam Pepper got that.
Kim is like not someone like that's not that was not their relationship.
And Kimmy will even say like Kimmy will say also that like they
did not it was not deep like it was not at least that's what
she said publicly or >> sounds like what she told Paul.
Yeah that's what she told Paul. >> Yes. That's what she
told me she told Paul. So it was confusing to hear cuz I reached
out to her about the Sam Pepper. I was like, "What? Sam Pepper's
like threatening to leak things." Like, "What did you tell Paul?
What was the narrative you told Paul?" And then she said, "Yeah,
I didn't tell him anything. I told him it wasn't significant
at all." Like, she had assured me that like there was no love
letter. There was like it was not significant to either of >> And
does it seem like the kind of guy to write love letters? I don't
know, man. That that message burner nose job was pretty he
like kind messages. I like a love letter I think is
not at least I mean it I think it's in his nature now but I don't
know maybe he did at one point I I don't it doesn't even really
make a difference but I don't think that he did but he is sweet
like Tim is a sweetie pie he's not he's not an evil person >> oh
hold on these logs are these logs are duplicitus I'd say okay
this is not this is not great not a great look for her we'll
see is that a good thing so yeah it says I want to actually try
to work as a team and not against each No, dude. If it all ends,
then I'll tell you everything. And if it doesn't end, then I'll
keep it in. Well, I can't really explain it to you, so that's
fine. Just believe what you want. This is like, well, if he is
leaving me, I guess I I can leave some
But do you see how it's a nondecisive thing? Like, do you see
how she kind of keeps everyone in this limbo about things? Like,
she >> It's not really a limbo. It's actually pretty obvious.
I'm just saying it doesn't sound It's not
like it's >> That's what That's what I said. Exactly. That's
literally what I said to you is she knows where to put the knife,
but she's not like it's very it's manip she's manipulative. >> Yeah,
but it sounds like she knows how to use the knife here, too.
>> That's Yes, that's what I That's what I said. She knows
how to use the knife, but she's not like very good at hiding.
Like, this obviously does not look good. She doesn't know how
to actually not make herself look crazy. >> I think most
people read this person think
write it off, but >> but a person with self-awareness would
not write something like this. Do you know what I mean? Because
this does not look good. This is incriminating. >> Okay.
Yeah, exactly. Soapbox. Yes. She doesn't know. She doesn't know
if she should use the knife yet. She's waiting. She's waiting.
She's getting a feel, getting a lay of the land. She's going
to figure it out. I So you say this, Cherry, but I got the impression
that Lav was saying she was not sophisticated before, that she
was like, a cow, that she had no consciousness.
>> No, no, no, no. That's not what I I I I think that when
you're with her, there's not like a spark of humanity. I I don't
This is why I keep saying I don't know if she's dumb or evil
because it's like it's not insult but she's obviously moving
like she's at least a little bit socially savvy.
So I it's she's it's sophisticated in some ways and then you
she but she tries to she what I think is that she tries to make
herself look naive. I don't know what it is. I I have no I am
not a doctor. I'm not a psychologist. I don't know what she is.
Yes. Someone alien mode said lab is saying she's pure instinct
with no intelligence. I think that is true. Yeah. Okay. We should
ask lab for some tips on manipulation. Yes. >> Sorry. I
had to walk away for a second.
all instinct intelligence sophisticated. Sophisticated but obvious
to anyone watching. Yes. >> Maybe I need to I need to shoot
this person a message and tell them that they uh they can come
tell their story on stream. Okay.
>> That would be
hilarious.
Well, I just want to know what she told everybody. I just want
to know what she told Paul specifically that she's not like lying.
That's it. >> Yeah. I want to know I want to know everything
she's thinking.
>> Uh send a message to the Hannah person, >> She's
going to ask you what sports you played in high school. She's
going to ask you what your three favorite ice cream flavors are.
>> What are we pointing to here? >> She's like trying
to be a human, but she can't. She's emulating a human.
>> No. I have you ever heard her like interact with anyone?
>> No, I didn't watch any of her kick or keep or anything
like that. >> I I think that you will understand what I'm
saying if you watch her.
>> Uh I'll figure it out when I talk to her. If I talk
to her, >> I think you should >> try to get Handridge
on. Yeah, I feel like that person would be a good one to uh message.
That would be Is Sam Pepper? S Pepper's a drama streamer. Yeah,
Sand Pepper does like all the There seems to be a couple people
who do the drama streaming like recaps for the space. Uh, Goon
does them too, I believe. >> Yeah. And he's doing one next.
And he's doing one when we get home on Monday on Monday night.
>> Based. Very cool. >> He's doing a whole He's doing
a whole recap of the scavenger hunt, not just the, you know,
the drama.
>> Who is >> all right? >> My my husband Goon.
>> Oh, nice. >> Bet. I want to play Battlefield.
I'm sick of this [__] >> You have to work.
I'm sick of providing for us. I want to play Warhammer. >> I'm
sick of providing >> Wait, Warhammer?
>> Oh, yeah. These two love Warhammer now. Well, I think
>> to get a real job. No. >> Yes, I would ask Hitler
to get a real >> Wait, what kind of Warhammer are we talking
about?
>> He does the actual tabletop game. >> Oh, let's
go, my
absolutely. >> Can you say that? >> Yeah, he's >> Yeah,
you can definitely say that. >> That's awesome. Aren't
you racist? >> He didn't even know that you were black.
Yeah, I feel really unsafe now. >> Yeah, I was literally
about to say
>> no, he No, he's not. No, nobody's racist. Nobody's actually
racist. >> I was told this guy's actually racist on >> No,
he's Do you not see Do you not see >> I read that he was
like racist to
his his friend Echo
black >> like band two
>> and he and he left immediately the second he heard about
it. the hotel room in like a huff and like >> I mean >> threw
the guy on the ground. >> But I throw down Forelli and
I'm racist so I don't know if that means anything. >> No,
no, no. I you you can be aware of patterns without being I don't
Nobody here is like
if you are black if you are black. >> I forgot I forgot
lab is absolutely the biggest racist here. I forgot. Sorry. Whoops.
My bad. >> That's not true. That's not true. Obviously,
listen. You're gonna avoid certain types of white people also.
You know what I mean? >> There's no way, bro. >> But
it's it's not it's not ontologically
because you're black. >> Yeah. I try to stay as far away
from white guys that do roofing, white guys that, you know, work
for me. >> Hold on. That's that's wild cuz Yeah, you get
the white guy who roofs phenotypes. So, I feel like that was
a wild thing for you to say. You stay away. That's some LTG [__]
right there.
>> I am the white guy that owns the roofing >> Yeah.
Yeah. white guy that does them. >> I sit on the ground
and bark orders. >> Oh boy. >> Nobody here's racist.
Everyone loves each other. Do you also do tabletop
>> I I do it on the computer. I do it on tabletop simulator
because I'm broke as [__] and I can't afford the
million dollar. Oh yeah, that's that's another reason why me
and Tim have been fighting is because he spent thousands and
thousands of dollars on these figurines and he won't even paint
them and he won't paint them and he buys more because he needs
more points, more army and uh it's just, you know, he's running
through my savings.
>> Well, he has my blessing.
>> Not my fault they keep changing my units and I have
to buy new ones. >> Yeah. Okay. >> It's not his fault.
It's true. I could back up what he's saying. Yeah.
>> Stupid. But he's
Nick. >> Did you network with Nick? We did with >> Okay.
Yeah, Nick's big into Warhammer.
>> is he really? >> Yeah. Nick Wick Lee. Yeah. >> Warhammer
said something funny about me. He was like he's like uh I don't
think I think he's a dumbass, but I think he uh >> he has
this way with words like Eminem where it's like vulgar and twisted.
>> Your instinct. Yeah. >> Your instinct. >> Pure
instinct. >> Yeah. But I we're getting into >> Dad
was just abusive. I just had to learn how to like cope with it
by being funny or being really ruthless.
>> Real. That's so That's so human, babe. >> I'm
human maxing. >> You're human maxing. We're getting into
Age of Sigmore, though. I just got um what did I get? What are
they called?
and flesh eaters. Yeah. >> Eaters. Yeah. >> I don't
know about Age of Sigmar. I ain't going to hold you. >> Okay.
Age of Sigmar. Is that not >> Is that not the fantasy stuff?
How does fantasy Warhammer connect to 40k? Okay. Hey. Yeah, fantasy
Warhammer. >> 40k is the one with guns and is more sci-fi
and Age of Sigmar is more fantasy. So, which I think is way cooler,
but >> bunch of crazy admit out loud. >> More girls
play Age of Sigma. >> I think it's way cooler. I'm not
>> Which is weird cuz usually fascists really like uh 40k,
but I I like the fantasy setting more. >> You said fascists
like 40k more. >> Yeah, it's racism. >> Yeah, it
is racism. It >> is literally space racism. Yeah, >> that's
all. And you're playing the black character. You're so not racist,
babe. >> I I play orcs. Like, how can I have so many orc
friends?
>> Is the uh Is there no more Kimmy logs? >> I think
there's definitely over. >> It's over. It's over. >> No,
there's definitely more. You guys need to see the big one that
she sent
>> The big one. >> Not sent me, but she talked to
me and then we got in a we got in a little we got in a little
battle. Wait, are you going to link those or
>> I don't have access to I don't I'm not in her server.
It was like through >> Dude, how do you not have them?
>> I've been kicked out of so many Discord servers, my
friends. I'm out of death. I'm out of I'm out of uh my roommate
Discord that I used to be in. Cute bots. Like have [__]
>> I destroyed you. >> I destroyed you. Um it's got
>> a Discord is so bad. >> Are you not in her Discord?
>> Huh? I'm not talking to you. I'm I'm
link to Kimy's Discord. Hold on. Let me go Let me go see if I
can get into some of these. >> I thought we would have
had enough of the CX drama frogs here now that they would go
and find these. >> How do you It feels like you only have
like a quarter of the logs.
>> Listen, I And I went and found all these myself. Okay,
we're doing we're doing on the ground work. Wait, not the Kimmy
logs. All the ice logs. I went I went and made all of my own
albums for this cuz uh people don't do it well. Okay. Who the
just goes to the search bar and leaves all of the context messages
out. It's so up. Like whenever I is like replying to somebody,
that's how everybody does logs for streams. They just go to the
search bar and they don't even go to all the messages individually.
It's like actually
>> Yeah, but it's like so [__] to try to tell
the story without anything they're replying to. Like you see
when I go to do these Kimmy logs, these ones and like uh the
ones from before, these ones where like you don't have message
could not be loaded. It's like dude, why am I guessing? You can
easily just click on >> Also, for the record, people in
the chat are asking >> what I play. I play Astra Militarum.
I do not play Tao. >> Oh, that's expensive.
You think you got
>> He's like,
[__]
>> he he has to pay $200 for dice alone.
>> Trick.
Not good. >> Okay. I'm looking for a Kimmy Discord invite
in the background. see if she's got one on one of her streams
or >> Is it not open?
>> Well, I'm seeing I'm I'm saying I'm going to go look
at her like socials and [__] and see if I can find
>> Bro, it's so corny to get people out of Discords. That's
crazy.
>> I've never been so mad at somebody that I needed to
check my Discord list again. >> And it all happened at
once. It was like a coordinated effort by all the girls to just
like remove me. Jesus, that is >> I just showed him the
riddle 44. How many black guys is king with me? Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, >> I just realized, dude, the way
you acted with uh Malik, you're a psychopath. I forgot I I watched
that content when you when you evicted Malik. You guys were
>> You guys were psychotic on that. >> Yes, he and
I was very mad at him for that. That was very strange of you.
But you have to understand that Kiana was like the ring leader
of that house and Kiana wanted her out. >> Yeah, I was
an enforcer. I played the bad guy to get [__] done.
>> And you had to continuously play the bad guy because
Keano was like too scared to like do anything. >> Yeah.
Like I I I'm not opposed to being like a bad person in public
so other people that are my friends can get away >> That's
why she thought that you were loyal. The second that you didn't
do that anymore, it was like >> Yeah. But between me and
my wife, like that's not going to fly. >> Yeah, but that's
different drama. That's different drama. >> Who the [__]
is Kiana? Kiana's Cubot. >> Oh, have you seen Cubot recently?
Really? Just >> no. Why?
>> Just curious. Nothing. No reason. >> Was she change
race or something? What is it? Like what does that even mean?
>> Kind of. >> Wait, really? >> Wait, really?
>> She has big booba and and like big butt and she she
did her hair. >> She got like She got totally totally totally
totally Don't open my downloads. Whoops. Uh she got like totally
bogged.
>> She got like all the plastic surgeries.
It was pretty crazy. She She still looks like herself though.
She doesn't like She looks good. >> She didn't look like
a different person. >> Was going to pick up Kimmy from
the >> Just pack a punch. That's all. >> She She
bimboified herself >> like that or something.
>> I don't notice any difference except for
>> I mean I didn't even I didn't I didn't even know how
big her
>> I didn't even notice any Wow. Is there something different
here? It's like it's not staring me in the face at all. Oh my
>> bro. I You're acting like I download how big every woman's
breasts are. I don't. I don't. >> You went on her stream,
bro. You went on her stream. >> I'd watch my participation
on that stream. Watch my participation on that >> Trying
to keep Darius from puking.
>> Lea,
after that stream, he passed out on the kitchen floor with bile
coming out of his mouth. It was disgusting.
>> I thought he was faking that. I thought he was faking
all the He had this big ass bottle of vodka and he was drinking
it like water. And I'm like, "Dude, he has to be faking this.
There's no way he's drinking that much." And yeah, he basically
they basically didn't let him on, right? Did they let him on
>> Yeah, they let him on, but then he kept saying the end
when they told him not
>> He
wins. >> That's awesome. >> Oh my god. Wait, they're
on riddle 49.
>> Are they Wait, does that mean that there >> If
they scan 49, then it's like it's over, right? They've already
got the 50th clue. >> Yeah. And then they have to get the
50th to win. The 50th is going to be really >> Oh, they're
on They haven't scanned 49 yet. They've scanned 49 will take
a while. 49 and 50 have to take like a day, I think. Right. >> They
He said it would take probably 3 days to do 50.
>> Yeah. It's going to be some convoluted multi-step with
triple chaos theory. Uh >> fly to Uganda to get one of
the stickers. Like, it's just >> I haven't watched any
of the scavenger hunt. What was the worst clue? The worst answer
to the worst clue. You know what I'm talking about? Like the
worst >> the Chaos Theory one was stupid. >> The
red blood.
Yeah. The Red Bud Island. >> He didn't know what true north.
>> Yeah. He didn't know what true north was, which was
so
>> So he gave a clue that didn't even point in the right
direction because he didn't know what True North was. >> Yes.
He's Yes. And so everyone was like so confused and it took like
two days and Yeah. It was >> one. Yeah. That was like three
probably top or 25. I think we were like not even >> Yeah,
it was it was
it was >> I'm a What is true north? >> True north
is like it. Have you you know what a compass is? Do you know
what a map is? >> Yeah, I I know what a Yes, a compass
is. Yes, I know what a map is. >> Yes. So, like true north
would be pointing north on like a on like a map or a globe. >> Yeah.
Like directly north position. >> So like north in from
wherever you are is different. Does that make sense? But there
always is a north. Wait, so north it be north being different
on a compass versus versus a map or a compass and a >> No,
no, they're the same. >> Yeah, a compass and a map are
the same. But he did not realize that true like for some I don't
even know how you're this I actually don't even know how anyone
could be this. He said in the clue like stay true or you'll be
sleeping with the fishes or whatever. Like stay true north. And
then he explained how true north meant from like the the island
you were at.
But that's not what true north is. >> Northwest and it
was up the river like >> Yeah. That's not That's not what
true north is. >> So dumb. >> And I I'm the reason
why they put that RFID on Snake. >> Yeah. Because
I led like a crusade of everybody at 9:00 p.m. to go to this
island and we were searching it up and down. There's a bunch
of >> That was you. >> Yeah. I led that charge because
I felt
>> and then they added it this year and then he's like,
"Oh, well, let's do two islands this year. Let's jump the shark.
And it was as usual. >> Yeah, it was super dumb. Just stupid
stuff like that. But the Chaos Theory one was actually Did you
guys see that? We got that. >> I I haven't watched literally.
>> We were We were the only people with because Warren
literally shout out Warren. Warren was the one who uh did that
for us and uh but he just didn't do it fast enough and we didn't
get it and we couldn't find the RFID. But >> no, no, we
showed up before anybody. >> Yeah, we were the only ones
who were even close. >> Dark and
like flashlights to find it. >> Yeah, that was super annoying.
Um but and he did not give that to he was like nobody's like
yeah he yeah >> wait do you remember which RFID that was
>> the windmill one the
>> like number
>> windmill windmill >> why am I saying windmill
why did I say >> no no the number which number RFID
>> oh do you do you like why how would I know that >> well
I asked if you would know it >> no of course I no I'm not
Rainman am >> like 10 cuz I got first for nine and I think
they might have [__] up how they're handing out prizes.
>> Like I got viewer first for nine but I I think I don't
think I guessed well. So I'm confused as to how I got it but
>> Did you get money for it? >> No, I didn't ask
him for my money yet. >> I I wouldn't be surprised if I
don't get my money now that I did the song.
>> You are a squad affiliate.
>> You're a marked man. >> I don't know why anybody
would like care about that. Like to be honest, I your friends
are cringe for doing that. Like Ice will come to his senses at
least on that front that he won't cut out people who talk to
you, he will. >> Like no matter what chicken, >> anybody
who kicks you out of Discords, right? If they're worried about
the Adriana Chicken stuff was a lie. We We're just trying to
like >> We're not going to We're not going to like put
our friends in a bed. No, we're Yeah, we were just saying like
Yeah, they obviously we're they're like our actual friends in
real life. So, >> we're not going to put a competition.
We're not going to tank their effort. >> I was being physicious.
Yeah, I was being physicious. >> I understand if anybody
doesn't want to ever speak to me or utter my name ever like that
makes sense. I like get your money. Don't >> They're still
going to be watching. You're too entertaining. >> Not up
on behalf of me. Like, do your thing. No, we got more messages
saying that uh
like good job than we did saying like can't touch you anymore.
>> A ridiculous amount of people have >> but people
are quiet. People are quiet because obviously Ice Poseidon is
like um a big big streamer. People don't like him though. I didn't
realize how much people did not like him. >> Really? I
feel like tons of people a crypto scam. People hate you. I don't
know. I don't think like crypto
>> I had no idea that he did a crypto scam until like yesterday.
I've never I'm not like a stream watcher. I never really have
been. So, I didn't like know the only reason I knew who I besid
was is because Tim had done his events. I don't really like know
and I know Sam Pepper. I know of Sam Pepper because of his tent.
I used to watch his tent when I was like 13. >> I don't
even know what that means. Got no idea. He used to he used to
have videos of where he was at Venice Beach where he was like,
"Let's see how many girls I can make make out with me when I
grab their ass." And he would like he would like go up to random
women, slap their ass, and start making out with them. And like
that was the content. It was like the most insane thing ever.
He said it was scripted, but it's like crazy. It's like the craziest
weird lore. >> I can confirm that is lore.
Yeah, it was like really weird. But I guess I guess it was scripted
is what? But that was his whole like pickup. >> Yeah, dude.
I just I wanted to see if you were on a what do you call it?
Like a kick or keep with Ice Boseidon. You guys realize you were
on this together. >> Me and
you. You two, Gunnar and Lav.
>> yeah, we we did this is when when do you know when this
was? We were on and off for Well, we weren't even really on and
off. I just wouldn't take the leap. But we at this point we had
done a lot of content together. We had done a lot of >> Oh
yeah. That's when that >> we got you on I literally got
you on this kick or keep >> I said I said I to Kelly I
think I was like I'll do it if Tim does it. If Goonar does it
>> and then you you got eliminated I think >> Yeah.
Nacho mama kicked me off. I called her an old bang. >> Told
her to go bake cookies for her grandkids and >> instead
of wasting her final years on
>> I look cute in that wig. >> You do look cute.
Uh, sounds like you deserve to get kicked off. Nacho Mama owns
you, dude. >> I mean, honestly,
I'll take the L from Nacho Mama. >> Yeah, she's she was
in your chat the other day. >> Yeah, I know. Doing tricks
on it. >> Shut up. You're so >> low denture tricks
on. >> You're so gross. But yeah, at that point, we'd been
on We've We've known each other for we met on a John Zirka Royale
three years ago. >> What the [__] is our life?
>> I know. In in August, in the in the middle of August
three years ago. And then for for a year and a half you were
like please leave your husband. >> Hold on. Hold on. I
just want to get this I just want to get this straight for everybody.
This guy showed up here and was like you guys are you guys need
to go to a bar and meet somebody. You met your wife on a John
Zirka Royale.
>> I want you to think about that. I want you to think
about that. Okay. I want you to think about it. >> [__]
true. >> Well that is a fair critique. Um I won.
>> that is true. You don't you don't choose when you meet
your soulmate. Sometimes you sometimes you meet sometimes you
meet them in the darkest of places. That's true.
>> That's You know that? >> Yeah, I believe that.
I believe that's >> That's true. It is true. You don't
You don't choose who you fall in love with. >> Well, you
do. >> I'm going to go ahead and go. >> You just
don't choose where you where it >> All right. Thanks, Chris.
Talk to you later. See you. >> That's it. You have no more
logs. >> Well, dude, I went and looked in her Discord.
Somebody gave me an invite to her Discord and there's no She
didn't do dump any logs with you. >> That's a That's not
real. Or No, they're not with me or at me. I was never in there,
but she talks about >> Cherry. Uh Cherry and I met via
streaming. Obviously,
so obviously we met online, too. Yeah.
Wasn't a bro. Sorry. Somebody in chat said there's a subtle cherry.
It was not a
pressing mommy. Are you seeing that? >> Yeah. G Mommy's
about to die. That's >> Can we I can't believe nobody who's
listening in the chat right now. I guess most of the kick people
must be watching ice stuff,
right? But uh I just can't believe nobody What? What did this
guy just say? Never been an ice viewer. Yeah, I know. We got
a really mixed chat. Really mixed group now, guys. What's Darius
doing? I don't know. >> Little G Mommy is being killed
right now and you're missing it.
>> get back out there again. >> No, please just let
him die. I feel like G Mommy's been begging for it at this >> The
cops are here. Is he in trouble? Remember when this guy got like
right hooked by Zirka?
>> that's all I know him for. and Tom. >> Yeah, that's
all I know him for is getting like knocked over.
>> Um, Zirka and Miss PBJ were fighting in the room and
Gammy and Sir Tom were outside the room just like knocking on
the door with him and he came out freaking the out. >> Oh,
yeah. It was a heel mic party, >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah.
The heel island. Nothing good ever came off. >> Those guys
had so much free money and they just had to around joking about
minors and then accidentally [__] around with miners.
I
>> Yeah, they had they had the world at their fingertips
and they just blew it all up >> for nothing.
>> They manifested that whole thing. Like >> that's
wild. >> God, this website's crazy. >> It is. There's
a lot of different metas. I mean, it's a very different place
than what it was when it started. That was like the first arc
of kick was like good and heal Mike getting banned. That was
where Kick was like, you know what? Actually, we do need mods.
We do need moderation. We do need to start cracking down on these
people. It's too much. stuck for a whole like 8-month period.
I
>> Dude, you guys remember the the stream where they had
the high schoolers there and Josiah is like trying to let Zirka
know like, "No, we didn't check the IDs." Zurka's like, "No,
she's 19, right?" And Josiah like literally does does like this
little headshake. I just remember this little headshake like,
"No, no, we didn't check anything." Z's
high school lacrosse team like holy >> dude. And heel Mike
was hanging out with them off stream and taking one of them on
dates to like Ruth Chris,
>> Like $300 dinners and bragging about it in Discord and
then oh my god brutal.
>> He remember having a panic attack on that stream >> when
he threw >> I actually did feel some bit of like damn Zerg
doesn't deserve this. >> Uh Zo is literally talking about
how he loves teenagers while fondling that girl
he but he really didn't know. He does >> he does like uh
like girls who look young, but I do think that he actually does
care about age.
>> he's not like a total scumbag like that. I don't think
>> I Yeah, I don't think he is either, but he Yeah, that
anxiety attack during that stream was really funny. And Jos Josiah
is like, "Hey, should we check IDs?" And he's like, "No, that's
gay.
>> [__] that. [__] that." >> Yes.
The problem was
>> the problem was Zirka like came up with the joke and
then Hillmike just picked it up and ran with it. >> And
it it didn't become a joke anymore. Like he just >> it
enveloped his life cuz he was trying to prove himself to Zirka
or something. Some weird like >> little bro complex that
he had his whole life. Do >> you know who Troy Gavon is?
Uh just just tek just what are you going by now? Are you still
going by Chad? What are you going by? Uh yeah, you can call me
shad. It's fine. >> Okay.
But you don't know who T. Gavon9
>> I think that you should look him up on kick right now.
T G O V O N I. >> Troy Gavon 68. >> Oh, is it? >> Troy
Gavon68. >> Troy Gavon68.
I don't think I got this right. >> This is like the greatest
live streamer known to man. >> Oh no.
Gavon banned a gun. >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no. >> Right.
Your your guy. Yeah, I've seen this guy in your panels and stuff.
>> My top guy.
>> He's our pet.
>> I think that you should
>> I Okay,
>> for some reason. Cuz listen, I I love Re. Re's always
on my stream. Lee's got a blood oath here. Or Re's got a blood
oath here. Okay. But I thought this guy might have been Reed
cuz he was like a huge super fan. And I thought I I just was
like, "Oh, maybe I thought this was the same guy for some reason."
I don't know why I thought I saw that. I think somebody joked
about it on a stream at some point >> and I just was like,
"Okay, I can >> keep that in my head." >> But I didn't
I didn't know it for a fact or anything. I re might have had
him as his um Re Hold on. Is this why? No, I I could have sworn
Call Me Re, I believe, had him as a avatar at some point. >> I
think that's what it was. >> So, I think that's why I thought
it was him. possibly.
Okay, deep chatter lore here. I'm looking for what am I looking
for right now? I'm looking for the videos of heel mike because
I just remember heel mike when when they realized this those
girls were probably underage, he started like going off on his
chat about how they're all and and f slurs for like trying to
please him on age. And I I just want to watch that clip cuz it
was such a spectacular fall from grace. Oh, come on.
God. I This video from Best Friend, but I don't think this is
everything.
October 26th last
>> dude. This was so crazy with like this whole thing was
wild. >> Yeah, I remember you Tim did like a lot of streams
about this. I think he was the one who brought him down.
>> dude. It's W for underage
girls >> Oh my god,
>> that's a random click on a random video, by the way.
W for underage girls drinking. Wow. I even told them I was like,
"You're going to manifest something very evil and up in your
life if you keep making those jokes." >> Oh, this cuddly
kissy video with like the teenagers. >> So bad. >> So
gnarly.
>> Yeah. Sorry. This is the This is the rant right here,
I believe.
>> This is what I was looking for like pretty precisely.
Oh, but Twitter video. [__] Hold on. Do it. >> Yo,
this is like
the whole barbecue. Do you eat all of it? Where is it? I don't
want it. I just was asking.
That [__] was born in night outside the bar. I was
like, >> "Okay, let's go for all that." >> Yeah,
I ordered liquor.
>> I thought you were. >> That was a close one.
>> Oh, and they go in. They're like, "Yeah, we check the
IDs. It's all fine, guys." >> Fake ID. >> Did you
guys? >> I didn't even know they made those. >> People
make fake. >> Oh, and Zirka just goes like, "What are you
doing?" >> It gets so much worse, too. I'm almost positive
right here. [__] this stupided ass joke. This is
gay. >> Get the out of here. Who gives a
>> What do you mean? This
>> like blew up everybody's missing.
>> you guys are the most about the energy
>> This is not all this by the way. >> [__]
hating. >> This is the Molly that he was on. >> He's
going to what? >> I did an IRL streaming. I did an IRL
stream with him and he showed me like the tin foil he kept his
Molly in. Yeah. I was like, "What the he doing?" Yeah. He was
crazy.
>> He used to work for Jerry Springer.
>> Yeah. He was like a writer for Jerry
>> He was like, "Dude, I wonder what he's doing now cuz
like he uh I think he's like way smarter than he let on." Right.
I thought
>> Dude, I thought he was like he seemed like an actually
smart guy when he was not high when he's just talking. He seemed
like intelligent. And I don't know. the best networkers I ever
met. >> No, he's he's like extremely he's um I think he's
smart, but he's uh he's like he's like a choice. He's like jumpy.
>> He's like just on a lot of uppers. >> He's like
a a billy goat. He's like a human billy goat. That's extremely
>> and in Yeah. And instead of eating all the grass, he's
eating every press pill he can get his hands on.
>> Jesus kissing.
I remember he showed me the Molly that he was on and I'm like,
"Bro, we're going to Dave and Busters
to Molly."
He did lines of Coke to go to a steak dinner with me and Neil's
Panda and Zirka and Spoon. >> Yeah, you're not Scarface.
>> Yeah, it was so weird. I was like, "What the is going
on game?"
>> that's wild. Okay, hold on. Check this out. Uh
Zirkus says, "It's not about the drink." He's like, "It's about
the kissing." And Mike goes like, "What? What kissing? Why am
I >> It's not about the drinking. It's about the kissing.
about bitching. >> Just the
bro over the over 18. >> 13. You were going to say who
are you going to say? >> 18. Who gives a [__]
>> Yeah, that's mine.
>> what the dude? >> It's just such a crazy crash
out for no
>> He was making so much money. Like it's it's actually
sticking.
>> Like you know how streamers when Nick was coming out,
they'll always tell you like what you what they're making to
a guy and then what they'll tell to girls that they're making
and the girl numbers like 3x to 5x.
But he was still >> to me literally you to me the whole
first two years we were talking. Yeah. Yeah. I remember I know
that. I know about that.
>> All right. Never mind. [__] >> [__]
you and my story >> cuz wait Zirka No, not Zirka. Kilmike
did a state contract too, right? Like I feel like I remember
him gaming. >> He had the biggest one, right? >> He
had one of the biggest steak >> Yeah. After train wrecks.
>> No, not after train like X and Z. >> but he was
he was definitely top 15 >> for what his stream was. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> And like I said, probably one of the smartest
guys. Like not scared to ask for what he's worth and even more.
Just completely like rinsed. >> He was also very cutthroat
as well. >> Extremely. Yeah, >> he's extremely cutthroat.
I remember when I was hanging out with him and Zirka on the podcast
for Neon Cyber Banda, he was uh he was talking about how he was
going to take down Action Man. They were like they were like
plotting to like literally take him down for like he was just
Yeah, he was very
>> They were like we have so much info on him that we're
going to drop and I'm pretty sure it was about something that
they got in trouble for. >> It's literally the same topic.
I'm pretty Yeah, I'm pretty sure that >> they were like
going to expose him for like something >> constantly says
that Action Man from the
>> He like Twitter account and Yeah. >> Yeah. I don't
know about that one. I've >> I think he DM'd her but didn't
know. >> Yeah, I've seen it for so long that like Action
Man does DM a lot of women. >> Yeah. I just think he didn't
know. >> That is so easily fakeable. Like it's it's just
so weird. >> He doesn't seem like someone He seems like
someone who would beat into Mils just by physiography alone.
That's what I'm going to rely on. >> Can't burn every bridge
on Kidge.
>> Oh, we love Action Man. I think
Boseidon. I'm gearing that one up for the recap stream. >> Keep
my keep my 15 minutes going. >> We We like Action Man a
lot. We think he's really funny and he is very sweet. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Makes sense. >> He was He was He's He seems
he seems like one of the more genuine people who has a heart,
but it's hard to be someone like that in this space, so you got
to kind of protect it. Um, I mean, I watched him watch I watched
him do stream. Do you remember the Anna girl from Destiny's stream?
>> I Yeah. Was she involved with Action >> Yeah,
she had a stream with Action Man. It was maybe the most like
brutal stream I've ever seen in my entire life. >> What
happened?
>> So bad. She got donations making fun of her the entire
time. He probably made like $2,000 in $2 donations just mocking
>> Like, what were they saying? Do you remember that one
last thing? Cuz action man's TTSers are like the most evil people
on earth, but they're so funny. Like when he had amaranth in
her Uber and that TTS is talking about like eating her horses.
>> She started crying. >> Is that real?
>> What the [__]
>> Sitting there with full volume >> cuz they Oh
yeah, they you guys were here. They played this. So uh >> Anna
Anna was a is a really sweet girl. She joined a group chat I
was in for a second and she seemed uh really fun, but like holy,
it was a lot. >> Uh I was kind of friends with her. She
leaked my DMs to Destiny after all that stuff came out. And my
DMs were, "Hey, I don't know if you've heard about this Destiny
stuff, but just uh let me know if you like know anything or something
like that." I was like, "Hey, you heard about this Destiny stuff?"
>> And then for some reason that got leaked to Destiny.
I was like, "Why? Why?
I >> Yeah, she's um >> Yeah, she she said something
when I was like, "Oh, are you still like friends?" She was like
I don't know. It was strangers all over the place. But yeah,
>> Yeah, I need to see this clip. >> Yeah. Is this
Hold on. Is this it? Cuz you said it was in a taxi. Would it
have been this stream >> one year ago? >> Yeah, it
was about this time period. I remember they were in the Uber.
>> Oh, this is literally Oh, there it is. >> Yeah,
that's the one right there. >> Bring her to the slaughter
house. bring her horses
to how Sarin bring her horses to the slaughter. >> We were
not talking about slaughter.
>> Slaughtering horses. >> Are you serious? >> Or
we knew that, >> dude. That's [__] action.
Man looks like he's terrified right now. Like, oh, [__]
I do. Hold on. >> He's confused. >> Aaron, bring
her horses to the slaughter house. Aaron, bring her horses.
>> He's just laughing. >> Bring the horses to the
slaughter house. >> Dude, we're not talking about slaughter
houses or slaughtering horses.
Are you serious? >> Kate, how do you feel about all >> to
read on it for best? >> He turned it off. >> He was
going for 20 minutes before that though. That was just the final
straw.
>> I'm sorry. You okay? >> He seems genuine about
it. >> He's not. >> Yes, he's not. He's not a dirt
bag. >> No, I think he does seem genuine about >> No,
no, no, no. You can't have the same script out the same script
play out a thousand times and then go, I had no idea what they
do. I had no idea. person. He has very he has very soulful eyes.
I
>> Action Man is not >> He is a I don't >> He
is what he is. Like it's not >> He's a He's a troll and
he's funny, but I don't I think he probably genuinely felt bad
if she was actually crying. >> He got upset with Ice for
egging on Zena and Darius. Um no, he didn't. He
>> He kind of took Darius aside, though. Was nice of him.
>> Did Have you guys ever seen that Thanksgiving stream
stream? Sorry with uh Action Man and Darius. And >> dude,
it's it's so crazy that Ice like gets mad at people for farming
his relationship when he farms Zena and Darius that way. >> Oh
yeah. And what was the other thing? Like Kimmy sent like a across
the bow when I reacted to her getting threatened by Ice and reacting
to it on stream. called it really like that's that's why that's
why she was threatening us is she in that big long message that
she had deleted. She had said something like and I I I saw that
you guys were making fun of us and he really didn't like that.
So I would just say and then that's why and then I was like girl
I'm like not mad at you. I don't know why you're escalating.
And then she was like I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I don't want
to make any drug. She was very it was all over the place. I but
she was like I don't know what she was mad at or if Ice was mad
at that or >> Yeah. I'm sorry for you. And >> I actually
don't know if I I don't think Ice actually would care. I think
that Kimmy was the one who cared and she weaponized Ice >> probably.
Yeah. And that's the thing. She was always trying to weaponize
his >> She Yeah, she does. Yeah, she did that with like
every every single person. But yeah, don't know. So I don't know
actually if that's even true. But yeah, it's it's strange that
I think he's just very egotistical. He's like obviously a narcissist.
He's been doing streaming for I think streaming for a month will
make you a narcissist. He's been doing it for >> let's
not throw stones in glass houses,
>> Yeah, that's what I'm That's what I'm saying. Like >> we
all know we're all scumbags. >> Yeah, it's just who has
the best dirt on the other person. >> It's just a game
of espionage. >> It's a game of power. Exactly. >> Power
plays. Like that's just what streaming is and that's what it's
become. Like I didn't start this, I ended it. That's it. >> That's
That's true. if you have something on someone. >> But now
everybody can just start telling the truth and we can all navigate
life like normal human beings and stop >> that's also true.
>> But they won't. >> Yeah, they'll continue. >> Espionage
is still happening. And I bet I bet you anything they stay together.
I bet you anything they stay together. >> Yeah, absolutely.
>> At least secretly.
>> I don't I think it's really I think it's really funny
that Kimmy is moving the way that she's moving about it and is
like he's a victim. I'm so sorry. He's like going through things
and you know it's because Red's due in two weeks. >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on. I think the only way for Ice to prove that
he is not still dating Kimmy is to like go out with Maddie and
Alexis and all these other streamers. Okay. He needs to start
hanging out with them all the time.
>> Yes. I said she should uh he should fly in Maddie to
do the uh the be the new host for Scavenger hunt so that he could
>> He should. He if he wants to show that he's moved on,
he absolutely could. >> That's what I would do. >> I
think would be good for him. >> There'd be eight women
on a couch right behind me if I was in his position. >> Yeah.
No, totally. >> I would scorch the earth and not jokingly
be insanely >> insecure. That would be hotter versions
of her. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> That would be like crazy insecure
to be honest with you. I feel like that would look half a million
dollars to fly and >> No, it's it's not insecure, but it
is extremely petty.
Ah, it's pretty insecure. I think
maybe Gunnar could get away with it. I don't think I don't think
Ice can after he talks about how like his girlfriend won't him
and [__] >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's
the root of the problem. Like she >> Did you read those
logs on stream goodter? Read Ice's logs after. >> Okay.
All right. >> No, he didn't really want to even touch it.
He was just like, "This is bad. I don't know what to say." And
even then, and you were even taking Kimmyy's side and Kimmy still
got mad. Well, yeah. I I explained it like he needs to learn
how to play the game and not rely on all his money and his status
and then maybe she could orgasm. Like that's just long and short
of No, like that's just if you can't please your woman, she's
going to find pleasure in other ways.
>> I'm sure that you could pleasure her. When I met you,
you like I taught you everything you knew. >> Yeah. You
suck like >> I taught you everything you knew. There's
no >> still can't even >> There's no way you're performing
the way that you say that you were performing. There's absolutely
no way. Not with the way that you were jack rabbiting me the
first time. >> Well, it's all about the humbling. >> I
excel in humiliation rituals, >> right? Okay. Yeah, I'm
sure I'm sure that you were giving her something that she's never
got before. Anyway, >> I'm looking I'm looking for uh what
do you call it? Looking for this album of Oh, I can find it.
Hold on.
Uh
See here. >> You need to find the rest of her messages.
Arf. Arf. Our argument was so good. Shut up. >> If anybody
can find those, if anybody were the secret memes what I said
about >> I was like I I think I said something. I was like,
you I was like, you've let a man without a mattress. And she
was like, and you married him. And I was like, he pulled in the
mattress for me, >> Okay. But yeah, I've not seen this.
>> No, it wasn't in your Discord. I think it was through
her Discord, but it was through like
>> Yeah, it was like forwarded messages and
>> just like female slinging missiles at each other. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. But it was so fun. I love like that. I love sparring.
>> Was this before or after the leak? This must have been
after the leak. Yeah, >> this was yesterday.
It was yesterday. >> No, that was when I was done.
arguing with each other or was it like across Discord or something?
>> It was it was with each other across
>> Oh, we probably covered some of that
>> like you you said you were going live or something.
Hold on. Was it was it this one? I guess I'll go live then. I
might have missed one of yours. You're sucking the of a guy who
lived in a pile of trash. 6 hours after meeting him. I made him
wait half a year. A year and a half. >> [__]
up. >> Jesus. you married him and I don't know if we get
the other one from you. >> I mean, she's like obviously
we obviously not she she was not understanding the point that
I I waited until he had like a mattress and a job to be with
him.
>> Oh, these are from like their >> That was the
gun to the camera crash out from like a month ago.
>> Wait, that was only I thought that was Japan where he
did the gun to the >> No. Uh >> oh. Japan
the punch the windshield and all that. >> Yeah, it's like
every three two months. He said, "I'm working my ass off." Well,
she sits home and does nothing.
Yeah.
>> Based on what I've heard from this gentleman so far,
I think she had a good point with you married him. I married
him when he his life was completely different. I I invested.
>> My life was completely
different. >> You had a You had a house, a job, a bed.
>> I literally had a desk, three monitors, and two blankets,
two pillows to my >> And that's when I A R15 and a SCAR
17. >> Oh my god. >> That's all I had in my Texas
house. >> No. And I would not touch you with I wouldn't
you with my sister's at that >> He says
>> king. Yeah, exactly.
>> That's crazy. I've Yeah, that's crazy. >> Dude,
I'm starting to pick up on like all of the lore and really put
it together. Like when I first read these, I had no idea. When
I read Bass Ghost is a good mod, but I can't have a mod if it's
over. Like I didn't know who Bass Ghost was. I didn't know the
memes. I know that she shot talks [__] about him.
Feel like Ice doesn't want Bass Ghost leaking more DMs because
this time he's kind of trying to poison that well, right? Hey,
Bass Ghost, she calls you short, just so you know. Makes fun
of >> I don't even know if him and Kimberly are talking
like I don't I don't know if if Ice and Kim are like on the same
page at all. He still >> They had a six-hour conversation
that Mayi and somebody else was in. >> Yes, but even after
that he was like, >> "He barely speaks English." >> Well,
yeah, that's true. But no, Ice had said something like, "Oh,
uh, Gunnar had just texted her last year about how much he loved
her and how she couldn't moved in. She couldn't move in." And
it was already like it had been a month since that was completely
cleared up and like the were shown to Kimmy like about Kiana
lying and Tim lying about that. like it was so it doesn't seem
like they're talking about anything like he he threw something
that was like
I guess it was just a Hail Mary but >> for her not to give
him a heads up on like a social situation like that kind of like
sparking up >> well because it obviously it makes her look
more valuable if she's like oh this guy was obsessed with me
and not like I've I let him me whenever he wanted and then he
sent me out of the room like that's not you don't you don't tell
your boyfriend something like that. >> Yeah, obviously.
Wait, also I don't believe that Ice Poseidon is confident enough
to ask for details on any of that stuff either. So I don't know
if when he says I don't know the extent. I feel like I feel like
he knows that you guys hooked up and he didn't want to know the
extent. I feel like there's no way he asked like tell me everything.
Tell me everything so I know. It's no I don't know. I I would
love to hear from Kimmy just like exactly what was what was said
to Ice about this. Yeah. >> Yeah. I'd love I'd love to
hear it. Also, I also think that the narrative that like that
she was his first choice and that I that he married me
after she said no or something, whatever he said is like hilarious.
>> Yeah, because Tim is was 25 years old. He's not like
look he's not we didn't he wasn't like serially looking for a
wife and like it yeah there's and he would literally on live
stream every time we fought hit up Kimmy in front of her
would talk about me on stream and she was still him while she
he was like denigrating her on live stream saying it was to make
me jealous like it was it was live like she she knew what was
>> and she knew that She was when she he had a girlfriend
back at home, too. She did not care. She just >> She wanted
Are you really going to moralize over that when >> obviously
Tim's the one who had the girlfriend back home or >> No,
I did you not? I've Me and Tim have been bickering about it for
the past two days. I I Tim has like a very extensive catalog
of misgivings of his relationships. It's why I did not It's why
we were not together for as long as we were not together. He
he he did things that were like very I don't know if I'll release
the text messages because I there's really not any point to bring
up like old drama between me and Tim publicly if we don't have
to. But he was psycho. He like he was psycho. Like he would he
was texting me while he was in the U-Haul with Kimmy
sending me songs saying you should be here. You should be here.
And I was just like dude like you're scaring me. And then he
was Yeah. Yeah. And then he was saying that he was going to lash.
He was just psycho. And then he was like, "Where's the loyalty?"
He told me that he slept with Kimmy. And then he was like, "Where's
your loyalty?" He's just psycho. He's like the most psycho. Yeah.
Whatever. And then he had a girlfriend when we met. And he was
like he there's scream. I have of him saying, "You and Kimmy
should fist fight for my love. You and you and Kimmy should wrestle
for me." Like just he's just annoying.
>> You find it awkward that you apparently married a guy
who loves turning women against each other for his own
Well, that's not So, we actually
when in the beginning, so it was really really This is actually
going to make me cry cuz it's actually kind of a sweet love story,
but it's really toxic in the beginning. Um, we met immediately
felt it like immediately immediately felt it, but I was obviously
in a in a different position. Um,
and I did uh the reason why I opened up that relationship was
this lore has already been dropped. that I opened my relationship
when I met Tim. Um,
and uh,
it was a it was a whole thing, but I wasn't I I didn't know how
to do an open relationship. I wasn't like I wasn't really I'm
not a girl who like sleeps around regardless of what you might
think of me. I'm like actually very protective. Um,
because I hate showing vulnerability. Not because I'm scared
of being a but because I don't think men I don't I'm like scared.
Um, so it took me a very very very long time to like trust him.
But in the beginning, it was like he was so upset that I would
not fly out to him that he kept doing things to like make me
extremely mad um
and fighting with me and like threatening me and what whatever.
It was a It was a whole thing. And then we didn't talk for 8
months. Um
do you remember why we started talking again, babe? Oh, because
No. Oh, because I I was in Los Angeles.
We're in Los Angeles and you hit me on >> I was in LA and
I was like, "Hey, are you still in LA?"
And he was and then we met in person for the first time 2 years
after we met.
A year after a year and a half after we met and uh it was like
it it was um
after that it was sort of dunzo. But it's actually a very beautiful
love story and I then I realized that he was just he was just
you know you you do the best you can with what you have. I think
it it was probably very crazy making to have the feelings that
he felt towards me and then me being being in a in a public relationship.
I think it was probably really confusing and for him so he did
some very toxic things to me but that was years ago and things
are um things are really good now >> for now.
>> Cool. Cool. >> Wait way we don't that is stuff
like that does not happen anymore whatsoever. The gambling is
the big the biggest
>> Okay. But but yeah, >> I that's like a whole thing
that I don't want to make. Like I can poke you over different
things, but I'm not going to poke over that. I don't I don't
like gambling evil >> about the gambling stuff. Yeah. And
I think I genuinely I think this website is extremely evil with
how it like the with the the gambling and whatever. And >> You
don't have to take the gambling money. You don't have to be a
part of the gambling stuff at all. People do, >> No, but
even but the culture of normalizing it is like crazy. Yeah, I
like Wes. Okay, Wes, by the way, Wes, by the way, has got the
best messages around this stuff. Okay,
I I told Wes, I was like, "Should I get a gambling contract?"
He's like, "I mean, do you have a gambling problem at all now?"
And I'm like, "Yeah, a little bit." He's like, "You will yourself,
right?" You like literally
basically the reason I apparently like all of these gambling
contracts are profitable is because people like you could make
out like a bandit, but nobody does because you actually do get
addicted. you actually do start having a gambling problem and
then it's like over. Like they you make insane money, right?
But they I think Wes a bunch of a bunch of months like he won't
even make a profit, right? Cuz he'll just gamble >> Yeah.
But but also there's I mean gambling addiction is so it's like
a passive addiction and then you don't even realize how bad it
is until it's like really bad. Like Tim was every single paycheck
he was using with kick when this is when we weren't together.
Uh but every single paycheck he was using he was like using all
of it to gamble and then an extra 500 a week to the point where
I had to like buy him his meals. And that's like how that's how
a lot of these streamers were like that's how so many of these
streamers who gamble online are living just like that. like they're
getting stake money, but it's it's predatory because they're
they are they're getting addicted to to spending and then they
spend more of their money. I don't I don't like it. I I don't
like this at all. >> I don't like it's a lot of >> So,
even like the the steak deals themselves are extremely predatory.
>> Well, everybody wants to be train wrecks cuz living
large. I wish I could sit home all day and spin like that'd be
the >> That don't even stop him. But I could still make
it. >> That is That's actually That's derange to even I
don't I've never wanted to gamble in my life ever. I don't even
understand why people do it. It It's >> It's just electric.
>> It's like burning your money.
>> It is burning your money. It's You have to feel it.
Okay. To feel it.
>> No. I Maybe if you're in Vegas like once a year and
you're like, "Yeah, I have $500. Let's see if I can make this
like if I can double it." >> Well, it started off as like
a group thing. Like me and all my friends would get in. >> Yeah.
That's the problem though is you can do it on the internet. >> Then
they tip their friends in and then we're all You ever had nine
slots on a >> Yeah, I could. Dude, your eyes are starting
to glaze over talking about this. You're starting to You're starting
to get very passionate and I'm worried about you. >> Same
way I talk about Warhammer. >> We shouldn't we shouldn't
talk about this anymore because I can feel your your energy shifting.
>> All right, I got to go somewhere. >> Yeah, literally.
Do not take a stake deal, Chad. >> Yeah, I won't unless
I get one that doesn't involve uh affiliate links. If I get like
>> I get one Saudi oil prints to use your affiliate code
and you don't have to work a day in your life. >> Oh my
god. >> He just got tiger running around his house just
spinning slots on a like bought a 5,000. >> You should
get train wrecks to use your >> No, he's probably I'm probably
blacklisted from any one of the top guys. It's >> You think
so?
>> I don't think Train blacklist people. I know that if
if he if he knew Train before this, I don't think he'd do that.
>> I think he's been blacklisted too many times. I think
he's been black. >> Whenever I have a big view count and
whenever I have a big view count and I raid train and he's doing
a giveaway, he just completely ignores my name. So, I don't I
don't know if there's like And then one of my friends will raid
him with like 45 viewers and he'll shout him out. So, I think
there's something there. I don't know. I could just be
>> he loves small streamers. >> He's Wow. All these
big streamers, Train Racks, Ice Poseidon, they just want to give
opportunities to small streamers.
>> there's no they're charitable. >> It's a charity
obviously. >> Yeah, obviously,
>> Is that Is that all the logs? >> I Yeah, I think
so. I mean, there's probably one more log from you or something.
I think the one where you say like at least you drag the mattress
in for me. I've seen that, but I >> Yeah, it is what it
is. >> We got the whole story. >> Unless there's
Unless there's something more, but I don't I didn't see more
from her anywhere. or like I didn't see big paragraphs from her
about you or anything like that. >> No, just the just the
cute but Oh, you didn't? No, she did. She wrote like a whole
big paragraph about how insecure I was and how her mom and Kiana
fed her. Cutebot fed her this thing that was like uh his mom
asked about you at the wedding because you were so sweet. She
like said that in the message was it was like extremely conniving.
Okay, we probably we probably did read that on stream because
I definitely read the whole thing about the marriage like uh
sorry when you guys were getting married and and Gunar's mom
mentioned
>> we read that somewhere. >> Yeah, that was around
the same time as >> Yeah, but my mom is like clueless and
she was coming down from like MDMA from the night before. >> No,
I mean Yeah, Kimmy is like a sweet >> Your mom
know about me? >> Yeah, everyone was on drugs at our wedding.
party once
>> except for Except for me. I was the only sober one and
and uh I was but they were they all saw Grateful Dead the night
before. So it was like a really it was a long night. But yeah,
that was that's why I don't understand Kimmy because she obviously
like
she she I don't know if she's stupid or evil. I don't know. That's
that is the question, right? With the ice beside stuff. Is she
stupid or is she evil? for her to weaponize my family like that
and bring them into it. >> why are you doing Why are you
trying to stake claim to my husband now? Why are you trying to
stake claim to She's calling me insecure and then she's trying
to stake claim to you while she has a boyfriend. Like, what are
you >> Wait, that's not even confusing. She's trying to
hurt you.
>> Well, no, but I that's I understand, but it's She's
making it so obvious that it's like a flail
>> and she's doing that. >> It's not a flail. You
guys addressed it and said it literally happened and had to explain
it. >> No, no, no, no. But she's doing it. She's No, I'm
saying she's doing it at the behest of her part. Like she's saying
that she wants to make things work with her partner, but that
now she is looking like she cares about Tim. Do you know what
I mean? Like it's not very >> She was just No, she's just
[__] with >> No, I know. Yes, I know that she's
with me, but when you are in a relationship and you're saying
things like that. >> Yeah, like if you said that about
some other man, holy, I'd be furious. >> Yes. Like if that's
like when who was fighting in Zena and Shui? When Zena and Shu
were fighting and she were and they were together but she was
still fighting Darius. It was like >> Yeah. I would be
>> What are you That's humiliating. Yeah. Like if you're
saying that you care about another man. >> Yeah. But hold
on.
>> No. No. No. What if Darius was like leaking a bunch
of crazy about her and like talking about how >> No, it
obvious it obviously it hurts her that she did not matter to
Tim and so she's trying to lash out at me. Um, no. Trying to
lash out at you cuz you obviously hate her. >> No, that's
not that's not what the scenario is because I didn't hate her
until she was a huge to me. The the first night that we met at
Dream Hack, she literally was like the weirdest person ever to
me and I was so normal. I There was no point where there was
any beef where there was anything.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. Goon, be honest. How much
did you use Lav to with uh Kimmy's head? Around the same time
you were using Kimmy to Lav's head.
>> Well, there's another girl that I actually was dating
back home that's involved in the situation, too. So, like
the relationships I was in. >> I actually didn't even know
that. Were you using me to with Kimmy also?
come on. Obviously,
obviously that's why remember all this, but I was playing I was
playing games. We were both playing. No, because No, no, no.
After that, she was she messaged me after that after they weren't
like they weren't even anymore. She messaged me after that and
was like with the Destiny stuff and was like, "Hope you're okay."
Like there was no there was never like beef like that. And then
all of a sudden we get married, we're publicly together
and she was immediately weird. >> Yeah, cuz she was very
nice to me before that. Before like while I was still with my
ex, like there was no there was no beef between us. Like we were
like there's nothing. The >> timeline is so weird. >> And
then when we were at Dream Hack, she kept looking over at us.
Super weird. Wouldn't like say hi to Tim. Wouldn't say hi to
me, which was super weird. And then when I did go up to her,
>> but hold on. You and Tim weren't together during the
>> when she messaged you, right? >> No, not really.
>> When she messaged you, it was nice. You guys weren't
together in person. >> No, no, no. Yes, she was nice to
me when she when she thought that me and Tim were not together.
But when she doesn't like both of you together, she knows she
cub
using you. I I feel like it makes total sense to me. >> I
don't even think that she got I think you were extremely explicit.
Yeah, you guys weren't like >> It wasn't like a I had to
trick any of these women into falling for me. It was like, okay,
with me and Kimmy, it was like, okay, we're both lonely right
now. >> And she was talking to you about Paul. >> Yeah,
we're in between relationships. We're both dating other people
outside of it, but we're just, you know, filling the void temporarily.
Like it's not, it wasn't this whole like big thing. We weren't
there was no future there. There was always an expiration date
built in. >> And yes, and she was nice to me during and
after that. Like there was no
In fact, I think that she was so nice to me because she knew
that you she was you were using her to [__] with
me.
I think she like liked that power play. Maybe it's so hard to
tell so many years >> Yeah, I I think that she really liked
uh and I think that she is salty
that you weren't actually obsessed with her. Like I think that
she really wanted to believe that you were because the second
that we actually got together, she was she did a 180. >> Yeah.
It's just super weird. The social dynamics in this game are so
gay. >> Yeah. It's I've never It feels like a movie. It
feels like a mean girl movie cuz she does the same thing with
Ice. Like I think and I'm I would be hardressed to believe that
she didn't do it with every man she's been with that she like
tries to posture even if they're not together. like why are you
but yeah as I was saying I think that I think that doing that
when you're actively trying to save your
and be like oh yeah and and
Tim's parents and like fight with me and trying to ego me over
my husband makes you look really if you're trying to stay in
your boyfriend's good graces I would be disagree if Tim was doing
that if Tim was doing that I would be really upset
>> yeah I I guess I just disagree in that like I think
She probably has some idea that that's what was [__]
people the >> Yeah, but why? Yeah, I Well, I guess she
is trying to hurt me because I exposed her for being a But I
Why would I Yeah, why would I not expose you for being a You
were like a c to me and your boyfriend sucks. So, it is what
it is. >> I'm just [__] Jones.
>> Want to be Eskimo Bros with the Arcane Dream, the law.
That's humiliating for me. Now I feel bad. >> I have like
comments on that, but I'm gonna That's fine. I do agree. Mitch
Jones is gross. Okay, I do agree. >> What are your comments?
>> He's just a worm. Like he I met him. He had the worst
handshake of all time. Like I I crushed his hand and I was like,
"Oh my god, I used to watch you in middle school and now you're
this. What the happened?" >> The limp the limp fish.
Say it ain't so. >> Worse worse. It was like It was like
silly putty. >> Oh, I don't even know who Mitch Jones >> Yeah,
it was just like an immediate immediately like, "Oh my god, I'm
disgusted by this fellow man." >> All right. Yeah, Tim's
having a Tim's having a really hard time uh with he he doesn't
like to believe the girls that he has with are he thinks that
he thinks that women who put out immediately after meeting him
are only doing it with him
>> and he does not dream, right? >> Yeah. He does
not like the idea that um the girls he has he's not winning over
the girls that he's having sex with. >> Can you agree with
that, Jo? >> This is the only way to look at
a guy.
>> I don't understand that. No, like as a guy
to believe that you have the magic touch that
women that is just true. Yeah. Yeah. I get it.
>> That's a really tough pill to swallow. >> I have
a I have a friend who like did a on the first night with her
boyfriend and I was like girl, he's like you you just told him
everything there is to know about you and he's like no I told
him that I'd never done it before and he just like believed her.
You guys will do anything to like genuinely
like protect that you that Yeah. that you are the man and you
she wanted to do that with just you. But that's not >> Yeah.
A guy wants to feel like the man. >> Yeah. It's copa. >> That's
why I love you because you make me feel like the man. >> You
Yeah. Because I made you wait a year and a half. So it actually
meant
>> I'd find you in any life and ruin it.
>> I think uh Okay. Before it starts getting mushy. Um,
you guys got anything else you want to chat about? I feel like
I might have to go find this action man >> I know that
this was this was fun. Thanks for I don't know how to get out
of this call. Oh, here we go. Okay. Yeah, thanks. I I think the
I think the drama is pretty much over honestly. >> Dead
horse. >> Yeah, I think we're our 15 minutes are >> I
think it's dead, but >> who knows? I'm sure there'll be
lots of other times for you guys to come around and uh >> yeah,
we're trying we're trying to figure out which we're trying to
figure out which one of uh the streamer's girlfriends Tim has
to next to keep us >> You guys are never coming to where
I live. Okay, I live in the Arctic so >> yeah we won't.
Okay, bye. >> See you. Wow, what a time. Portoeller, if
this is the same picture, I'm going to lose it. Portortoella,
what are you doing? Portortoella, what are you doing? Can you
chill? Can you chill the out? Portoeller, what the are you doing?
Definitely. W stream. Yeah, that was awesome. Guys, if you like
the content, you want to support more content like this, go ahead,
follow the stream, join the Discord,
All right. Follow me on Twitter. Follow me on Twitch. twitch.tv/jstlk
with an underscore at the end. Same un same at on both platforms.
Okay. Both on Twitch and Twitter. Why is Borterbeller? That's
true. I love this vid. It's not related at all though. >> Just
want to let you know you made my day. That means nothing to me
in front of their mouse. >> Wow. Sorry, I was in the middle
of doing my shill. I'll let this play muted. Okay. Okay, guys.
If you really like the content, you can donate some money. You
can give some money to me. You can make the stream go longer.
Okay. There's a couple ways you can do that. You can give subs
on kick. You can sub on kick. You can give subs on Twitch. You
can sub on Twitch. You can prime on Twitch. Prime subs. I love
individual subs on kick the most because if you individually
sub on kick, okay, that's rolling monthly income for me. There
is TTS messages. Okay, you can buy a TTS message. Exclamation
point. Donate in the chat. We'll give you both links. There's
Kickbot. There's Streamlabs. Okay, we got both. $2 $2 minimum
on Streamlabs. Sorry, $2 minimum on Kickbot. $3 minimum on Streamlabs.
Uh yeah, buy a TTS message. Okay, AI AITTS on Kickbot. Finally,
last but not least, is Patreon. patreon.com/jstlk.
All right. Lots of perks in the Discord. Go join the Patreon.
patreon.com/jstlk.
It's uh it's just nice to have a different platform in case anything
ever happened to the kick. I've already got like a little bit
of income, a little bit of something rolling on another platform.
Okay, so go sign up there, guys. Really appreciate everyone.